We're live.
Jesus Christ,
man.
I'm tweeting Ustream.
Dot.
TV Ford Slash J o.
E r o g.
A n.
Boom tweet,
uh,
fresh from making big foot his bitch.
Ladies and gentlemen,
Les Stroud.
What's up buddy at Joseph foots fun scene and I,
man,
I know,
I'm like,
he just got off stage at the comedy store,
which I couldn't believe you were there and I was here.
Oh perfect.
So I was like,
yeah,
there's David spade.
Amy Schuler.
It's like Stella.
And then you get totally brought your engineers.
What was like what it are these guys like sleeping?
No,
Brian was getting into the studio store to Brian was at the store and Jamie,
I told him today that you were going to come by.
I alerted him this afternoon.
We had worked out accommodations and here we are.
He got energy,
man.
I,
while you're flying them all morning to write,
I do what I like to do.
If you do what you like to do,
you got an energy.
I know.
And both my,
like my camera man and my field producer,
they're completely,
my bitch is not because they're not here and they're like the biggest fan of
you.
And I'm like,
so,
so you're gone go out to bed and there they've got a bad,
now they're going to bed at the Sheridan.
It's like,
okay,
well your pussy,
so I'm gonna,
I'm gonna go hang with y'all.
Sleep is for the week sometimes.
Sometimes good.
It's good idea to get sleep.
It's a renewable resource.
That's what you got to recognize and if you have an opportunity to do some shit
that you probably couldn't do,
except if you stayed awake,
you got to stay away.
If you don't stay away,
you're not willing to suffer.
You can suffer a little if you can't pull an all nighter,
you don't get all nighter memories.
That's right.
I got some all night or memories from when I was in high school.
Van Sleeping,
sleeping meant when you know,
I know I'm getting freaking older and I'm still like,
okay,
I want to sleep less.
Actually you do sleep less when you get older at the top.
Testosterone is not flowing as much and you can't do that like sleep until noon,
shit anymore.
You can't do that as you get older,
which in the end is a cool thing because you can hang out longer.
You're just older,
you can,
but you can also get up at eight o'clock in the morning,
jerk off and go right back to sleep.
That works too.
That does work.
10 sleep,
you just got to,
got to fucking make sure you schedule it.
You got to wait as long as you wait so long as you wake up hard,
then you know you're still alive.
Not So,
not necessarily.
It might mean just have to pick.
He boners the best.
That's Deon.
Deon are useless.
They barely feel them.
Who's Dick is this?
You can't really use them actually either.
Ken,
but you can't use,
it's not the same though.
They come doesn't want to come through the piece and you say lasts longer I yes,
exactly.
It's,
you're like this,
this fuck.
We started at the bottom on this interview,
so we're drinking.
We just got back from the comedy store.
It's one o'clock in the,
it's almost one 1230 in the morning.
It's late last time with you it was like 10:00 AM but it was all dark inside and
we only had it.
We had a beer and what's it only 10:00 AM 10:00 AM in the morning when we were
doing,
but this is the way more realistic.
This is better.
Yeah.
This is,
well I like doing different times.
I think there's good doom during the day sometimes,
but it's also good to do it at night sometimes.
Especially like we've never done it like live like leaving the comedy store and
come in here,
but that's,
it's a move to do.
I mean once the first we own this joint,
we just come in anytime you want.
Why not?
It's like,
it's like cutting an album man.
Neil young used to only do everything after midnight.
He probably did a naked too probably,
you know back then before TMZ you probably,
everybody's on acid just recorded stuff that sucks.
Throw it away.
I just don't want to picture Neil young naked at this moment.
Just open up.
They usually have strippers recording studios late at night.
Yeah.
It's not just all dudes.
So where are they now?
You don't want to answer.
They fuck up the dynamic.
That's a good set tonight.
Thanks.
That was awesome.
I was telling,
I was telling Joe I was,
I was texting him at one point cause I was listening to,
I was listening on comedy central cause I'm just addicted to standup comedy.
So tonight for me was awesome.
This will just go in and see all those,
all those great comedians.
And I texted him and I,
and I realized,
you know how like some comedians have like a Shtick,
right?
Like the most obvious was like Jeff Foxworthy with as he might be a redneck
stuff and and all that.
And with Joe you were nailing into this stuff and I,
and I was listening to,
so he's got a riff thing that he does.
There are analogies as called it and I start calling the rogue analogy cause
it's like,
well you know like when you get up in the morning and he got to say,
well,
like an elephant giving you a blow job through a straw and you shouldn't go.
Like,
actually that is kind of like an elephant.
Can you blow job here?
I didn't have a joke about it.
No,
this is bad paraphrase and Liz gentleman from a drunk man dare you.
How dare you.
But you got the analogy down.
You do that.
I'm not,
I'm not doing like the Joan Rivers blow smoke up your ass.
It's like,
Shit,
you got that down and you,
I mean,
because I'm a standup comedian,
just I love it because I suck at it.
I could never do it scares the crap out of me.
I couldn't tell a joke to save myself.
But listening to you to do that and listen to you go into those analogies and
it's like,
I'm going,
Oh shit man.
That's right.
That is like that.
And it is like an elephant.
I think pretty much anybody's ever made.
Anybody laugh can do stand up.
It's just a matter of do you want to do it?
If you wanted to do it took a long fucking time,
but we all know guys who sucked at it in the beginning,
but they were just such fans of comedy.
They just kept chipping away until eventually they figured it out and now
they're like legit standups.
It just,
it happens.
I figured that you're 15 minutes out there.
I just did 90 minutes fats in La and Vegas from my,
with my music when my concert.
Right and I did these concerts and it was great.
We kicked ass.
I figure my 90 minutes is barely as tough as your 15 minutes and says my friend.
It's just different man.
If you put the kind of time that you've put to searching for bigfoot and writing
music into standup comedy,
you'd be really good at it.
Yeah,
but I'm not going to,
I'm not going to cut,
dude.
How many mistake foot shows are you going to do before you catch this
motherfucker?
Yeah.
I need to know you don't already have them in the cage.
And My base,
he told me,
come on man,
I'll tell you,
it's,
it's really,
it's uh,
really,
um,
man,
it's,
it's a bizarre thing to be part of all of that and what's going on and,
and how I ended up in this position was because there's so much bullshit in the
field.
Like there's the nonsense that gets put out with,
you know,
you got to show where you're trying to find big foot and you've got to crank out
13 episodes.
So you need to invent these crazy stories and silly stories and stupid stories
and nothing much is going on.
And I nothing,
nothing,
nothing.
And I come along and I'm like,
okay,
you let,
you know what?
I'll just talk to these guys.
These dudes are into big foot and you say he's there,
you got him in a field,
you're doing it.
Okay,
take me there and I'll tell you what,
lead me there in the field overnight.
Oh,
let's just see what the happens.
And so I approach it.
I did six shows this year.
First one premiered last night.
We were talking about this before the show aired,
but I bears repeating.
You might have invented the selfie.
Yeah,
yeah,
I know.
I know that.
I was underneath the Van Guard of,
it's very borderline because you did a lot of shows where it was just you all
alone in the woods with a camera pointed at yourself and you,
you had the lens.
You know,
like if you look at those little video cameras that less used,
you know they have that viewer that you could look at you or you could turn the
camera towards you and flip this view around.
He could see what you're filming when you're filming yourself,
which is like a selfie.
So you might've been video selfie.
Nobody was doing it first guy.
Nobody were the first selfie guy.
The thing I,
the thing I did with nobody else was doing was I put it on television,
international broadcast TV.
That's the whole thing.
It's one thing to do it.
It's another thing to base a whole freaking show on it.
Way Worse than that.
You did it by yourself in the fucking woods.
You did it in Africa.
You did in the jungle.
You did it in the swamps.
You did it in the desert.
Just you not like that fucking English guy sleeping in hotel.
We don't even say his name on this show.
Good that English fuck sleeping pretending to fall down ice slides.
Johnny Appleseed,
that guy that Johnny Appleseed.
Fuck.
Oh man,
I could go so far and that me that's you're right.
Cause it gives credibility to shit.
That guy only exists because you weren't willing to fake shit.
That's right.
You weren't willing to fix shit.
The producers wanting to fake shit and they said,
okay,
we'll get Johnny Appleseed to fake some shit.
Yeah,
that's,
I am swinging from vine to vine looking for steaks.
Bitch,
you ain't any snakes.
You're gonna eat filet Mignon.
You own at the four seasons.
You fucked as a van waiting to pick you up.
It's air condition.
You've got off all over you.
You sleeping in fine linen,
fine linen and was luck.
It was very pretty though.
It's very pretty.
Still very pretty.
You're beautiful character.
You've got a different kind of pretty going on.
Yeah,
it was.
It was,
it was,
it was messed up.
It was,
you know,
I got,
I got asked over long time and I,
like I said,
I'll never put it down on the networks.
I'm still good with the networks and networks are great.
Didn't I was coming down to my day.
I care about that all it comes down to one person.
It's all,
it's one person.
All right.
It's one,
it's one ice that that's just like,
oh,
now we need you to crank out a bunch of these.
I actually got asked,
I actually got what one producer asked me.
They said,
no one will ever know.
And I went,
yeah,
they will.
Yeah,
And I'll know.
And that's,
I said,
no,
no.
And along comes the bullshit often.
Well,
it's not their fault.
It's like that's what they do on every other show.
What they do is these artificial scenarios,
even whether it's pawn wars are fucking storage wars or oh,
we gotta get this car finished by Friday,
man.
No,
you don't.
You don't don't have to get this car.
You do whatever the fuck you want to do.
Whatever.
I thought,
I remember the last,
the last podcast and Mary,
you said you loved reality TV,
you thought and I said,
ah,
I hate reality TV,
and I thought that's that's,
I'm not John.
I know you did man.
As
he's mocking,
she knows me better than you.
I don't love reality shows like some shows it look like life below zero.
That's a dope show.
That's a legit show that show,
that show they don't fuck around with.
I was liking that Alaska,
the last frontier show until I saw this fucking bear eating a filleted salmon.
I'm like,
Oh,
you're baiting the bears.
You assholes.
All that stuff set up.
I mean a lot of them are life below zero is not set up.
I know that for a fact.
That's a show I had this woman sue Akins on the show lives up there 200 miles
above the arctic circle.
That bitch is gangster as fuck.
She lives up there by hers.
She got attacked by a bear.
She got fucked up and broke her hip bit into her skull,
fucked her up,
broke her leg.
She went back and shot that bear and eight it pitch doesn't give a fuck.
She got serious years old.
She's a grandmother.
She smoked cigarettes every day.
She drinks whiskey and she lives by herself in a tent because you can't have
permanent structures like that ladies on hundred percent legit.
Okay?
There's that shows legit.
There's a few of those shows where those people live in such bizarre lives.
So you don't have to set up some film.
We need to get water.
We've got to figure out how to make this pump work again,
that's all stage shit.
They'll pretend something's broken so they have to fix it.
So they have some solution to some drama that comes up.
But if you live in a harsh enough environment,
you don't have to invent the drama.
And that's what you did.
Well you did.
You were the first motherfucker who went out there.
You really were starving.
You would see you on day one and then you would see you five days later you look
like shit.
Like you couldn't fake that you are dehydrated.
You were shrinking.
You would talk about it.
You couldn't sleep.
You had bugs crawling all over you.
Rats running across your fucking sleeping quarters.
Dude,
you really did it and you,
you,
you did it by yourself.
It's so much different than what these fucking people are doing with these
people we're doing.
Is this baby fucking us?
They're feeding us a spoonful of shit.
They're making it out to me.
They're making a mockery of something.
I mean,
Johnny Appleseed
before survivorman there,
there was no survival genre.
There wasn't,
and now the PLF,
the plethora of of shows.
I was watched one where there was,
let's just say dual people surviving and and San.
We've seen that show too.
I know one of those guys,
that guy is long gone.
He,
he,
he's God.
He could see the real guy.
Was He?
No,
he wasn't legitimate.
If you,
if you're going to go barefoot,
okay,
how about this?
No tools.
You fuck.
You won't even wear shoes.
How about dare you?
How dare you treat me like fucking lame ignorance.
You don't have shoes on.
What if you don't have shoes?
What have you don't have matches you fuck no,
you don't have a cell phone or gps.
What if,
what if the director is not going to say cut and you go back to your hotel room
after this?
That was like the one I was watching the other night that led into my show.
There was a sort of like,
what will they do next?
They've got us and you'll look at,
and they're crawling out of the snow shelter in the morning looking like they
just had a shower and just pressed their clothing.
It's like,
you know what,
I've been there.
You don't look like that after a night in the fricking snow,
you'll look like hell.
And they're all nice and clean,
the beard trimmed and everything's good.
And it's like,
what's like the walking dead?
The girl with the dark hair,
she's hot as fuck no matter what.
It's never,
never had zits,
you know,
I love to do a cameo on that show.
She was like perfectly placed mud.
We have an end.
We know Josh McDermitt.
Oh,
he's the fake scientist.
He's a good friend.
I mean,
I mean tell him,
tell him I'm caught up now.
That's,
that showed us so great.
She's as Christ.
That's good.
I do everything through like my son.
I just wait and he was just like pick a show and he was like in the walking dead
is one of those shows.
We got this big screen at home and say,
oh,
I don't know.
I sat down beside him for like a moment.
Oh,
what are you watching?
And like three hours later I'm binge watching,
blocking down like,
Oh shit,
this is awesome.
Binge Walkin Ism Shit.
That just didn't exist in our time.
We never binge watched and show you couldn't do it.
This is a new phenomenon.
People getting bulging discs and shit in their back.
They're sitting for 20 hours in a row.
People go to the hospital.
It was a fucking getting massages.
People are jacked up,
man.
Just from binge-watching.
Well God bless science shadow there.
They're putting survivorman marathons on.
Well,
there'll be like eight hours of survivor man shows and I'll get postings from
people's that they're watched,
all of them.
I'm just like,
wow.
How did you go from doing survivorman to survivor man,
big foot.
Now you told the story on our show that I've repeated ad nauseum.
Cause the fascinating story about your first experience with something that you
couldn't explain.
You were in Alaska,
you flew in very remote location and you heard something that sounded like a
primary.
Yeah,
some bipedal priming.
You know what the bottom line was?
I thought,
okay,
who's the one person that can,
you could take and drop in the middle of nowhere,
in a middle of a big foot hot spot and leave him alone to see what happens.
Well,
will be.
Every man has to be you.
It's got to be me.
It's not me.
So I said,
fuck,
let's do it.
I'll do it.
And then I'll go after the like,
cause I know you hate one of the dudes that I went out with Todd standing.
I don't hate him.
I don't know him,
but I know,
I know bullshit.
When I see bullshit.
We'll listen for the first one,
calling the bullshit.
Let me show them an image.
Let's show an image.
Jamie,
pull up this image.
This is a close up of a big foot,
and I'm doing air quotes,
a big foot.
You got this Jamie,
pull that shit up.
Show that show the prior,
right?
Right,
right.
This is a close up.
This dude just got a big foot to stand still.
He's the only guy in history.
Got a big foot and he's got two other shots like that.
So the question I asked you is,
the cool part is,
look how bad that looks like a perfectly trimmed here.
Now why does it look totally different in that picture?
Then the other picture,
I get it.
I see what you're doing.
What is that?
What?
Okay,
but let me ask you again just for a second.
Look at it.
Okay,
now what?
F or what don't you?
What if me?
You fuck.
What if we're full of shit and it's real?
No,
we're not.
And that's not how we do.
You know why?
Because every animal that lives every fucking animal that lives,
yeah,
looks like that animal.
No animals.
Look at a person in a fucking animal costume.
When you see something that looks like a person in an animal costume,
it's a person in an animal costume.
It's our outcomes razor or it's actually is.
Nope,
it's 2015 that is some shitty fucking special effects.
That is a dude in a monkey suit.
100% 100% or Syria wrong.
First of all,
what animal that's Harry ever has his hair matted down like that,
like it's combed and I have to say the exact same thing.
Good ass fucking costume pieces that things got aquanet on it.
It's Harrison great in place.
He's working at fast food joint too.
That looks so stupid.
The idea that that could possibly be big foot.
That's,
that's 100% a human being.
You know why?
Cause it has human being dimensions to its face.
You look at a gorilla,
you look at a chimp,
you'd look at it orangutan,
they have a different facial structure.
Oh,
100% day.
That's a human facial structure.
Absolutely.
The ratio between the nose and the eyes and the lips and the mouth.
That's,
that's 100% of human being.
I'm a shitty ass task.
Dr. Joseph [inaudible].
I am a scientist.
Okay,
let me do this.
Sorry.
Let me do this way.
Okay.
So,
um,
okay.
Okay,
so let's call it the scale of believability.
Okay?
Okay.
And that's a zero.
All right,
so,
so at,
at this point,
let's forget,
anybody who thinks they don't exist at all,
let's just,
Jamie's at a zero.
What does that,
is that zero to zero and you don't to say it's a series
like Joe's looking at me.
Everybody wants to say 100% fired man.
He said it's 100% big foot.
I give him a raise.
Jamie,
come on Jimmy.
Come on.
You know,
that's our big foot.
You Lester,
Lester out.
You know,
that's not big.
Fucking,
let me go back to what I was saying.
Come on.
Be Honest.
If you had a bet,
your your beautiful son over there.
Yeah.
If you had a bed his life as to whether or not there's not.
It's not big chunky suit.
That's not tough at all.
That's not even a little tough.
Why is big foot stand still staring at a fucking camera?
I saw leading up to this,
I saw the,
Oh,
the shifts to this footage.
The footage.
Right,
but you weren't there.
No,
no,
of course.
It's fucking guy you're hanging out with.
No,
not hanging out with him.
Believe me.
Let me,
let me,
I hung out with so many of them now and it's the whole shit.
That's what I want to get at.
Okay.
Okay,
so let's just pretend.
Forget the people who don't think it exists at all.
Let's go to those who thinks that it does.
This is the biggest problem.
You get to scale a believability on the left side of the scale.
You've got gigantic path.
It goes,
it's a big upright walking ape.
It's the missing link.
Well,
how about you to Jane Goodall?
I'm side of the scale you've got.
Jane Goodall believes it's real.
Right?
Okay.
Exactly.
As an eight as a species neanderthal,
maybe slightly humanoid.
He keep coming towards the center of the scale.
It's like,
oh,
it's really stealthy.
It's got certain abilities and you keep come close to the middle of the scale.
It's got tons of incredible intelligence and everything.
Okay,
now you hit the middle of the scale.
Okay.
On the far right of the scale,
it's always a far right.
The fucks everything.
I know the far right it does because you know what the fire of the scale is?
Aliens.
That's an alien aliens.
So then you go to and on the far right,
it's like paranormal,
walkability,
fifth dimensional vibration will control all sorts of shit like that.
Trail cameras.
So the crazy,
yeah,
they can control electronics.
They can do infrasound and screw you up like a lion or a tiger.
The craziest part is the argument is not between those who don't think it's real
and those who do.
It's within the scope of all the people who think it.
Israel.
That argument is insane.
Like the backstabbing and the fighting.
It's like no.
And all the eight believers don't want any of the paranormal believers to say
anything cause they're all whacked and screwed up and we don't want them to.
And all the paranormal believers don't want go to the eight believers saying,
well,
you're all close minded.
You're not open to the fact of that does this.
And it does that.
And it's this big cesspool of argumentative like shit going on.
UWF.
Yeah.
So
it's exactly like WWE is a lot of times,
you know what,
that's dad's WWF is like the 90 [inaudible] stands for like what the,
what the fuck?
Whoa,
whoa.
What the fuck that and what I did,
I dove right into that scale.
Right.
And land myself on the land out in the bush with all these different people and
try to be as objective as well.
Yeah.
What I said is don't make me your poster boy.
I don't want to be a poster boy for eight believers.
I don't be your poster boy for Alien Believers.
Just put me out there and show me what you got.
Let's back this up.
For people who don't know,
like you learn what a big foot,
gigantic pickers with the fucking gigantic,
gigantic Opeth Agus is a real animal,
did absolutely did exist,
but they only have a few bones and they founded an apothecary shop and China,
and like the 19 early 19 hundreds some guy found some teeth that he knew were
not,
uh,
any known primate.
And then he said,
where'd you get these teeth?
The people that run the apothecary shop lead him to this area.
They do a dig.
They find some job bones that indicate that this animal was most likely a
bipedal primate,
although that's under some dispute.
So what this means is there was something that was somehow or another related to
other primates if they think it might have been in the orangutan family.
But this is a bipedal enormous animal that absolutely existed at the very latest
100,000 years ago.
It could have been earlier,
but they know a hundred thousand years ago,
that thing was alive.
So a hundred thousand years ago,
which were there,
there were 100% human beings at the time.
There was a fucking eight to 10 foot tall,
gigantic bipedal ape,
which is big foot.
I mean it fun.
It's a real fucking asshole that's going out at one tidbit to that as a fact
that if it doesn't,
if it,
if it's extinct,
it's the only primate from that era that is extinct.
All the rest are still alive.
That's not totally true because that the Flores man that a hobbit man and the
island of Flores,
that little thing is dead and that thing lived closer to today.
They have bones from that little fucker that was like 13,000 years ago.
How you know it's dead.
That's true.
Yeah,
that's true.
I mean that's your red pen deck and that's what everybody's saying is how do you
know they're extinct?
I know that it was so intelligent.
They're just hit and the vast forests of North America,
that's a legit question because if you go out to the forest,
you know you don't find scientists,
you know,
I'm fucking fucking finding scientists everywhere.
Serving every inch of the land.
It is quite possible.
Like,
you know,
there's always these weird animals.
They find like that vampire deer that lives in Vietnam.
Like what the fuck is this?
They have some Fang deer,
like they'd talked about it like villagers or talk about,
and then my VA,
you found a Feng dear.
Okay,
good luck with that.
But they really did find this goddamn thing.
See if you pull that up.
Jamie Fang dear,
I think of Vietnam.
This was like,
this is a mythical animal.
The gigantic chip ends chimpanzee they found as well.
Yeah,
the Bondo ape.
That's a real animal as real.
They know now a logical,
until they found it,
the giant squid mythological until they found it.
Just stories.
And that's the whole thing that happens with the cryptozoology look,
that's up with just a story.
It's a deer with fangs,
right.
What the fuck is that?
Now,
if I'd said to you before they discovered it,
you know that there's a deer with fat vampire.
Yeah.
And you said not a chance,
man.
They didn't even find one of them.
No.
There's a,
well,
it's a very densely populate or densely wooded area,
but they know there's a family of them living there.
It's not just one.
They've,
they've observed more than one of these weird deer and the,
uh,
the champs,
the Bondo Champs,
they have photographs of them.
They have tissue samples,
they have hair,
they have photographs of dead ones.
The huge,
yeah,
they know for sure.
That's a real animal and it's different.
It has a crust on its forehead.
They have skulls of full intact skull of a recently dead animal and it was a
crest on his forehead,
like a gorilla,
which chimps don't have.
So it's really confusing,
which takes it out of cryptozoology and into,
into,
yeah,
that's the real animals.
I mean,
they have photos of it,
they have videos of it.
They have scientists that have gone down there and seeing him.
Carl Armaun,
he's a Swiss wildlife photographer.
He started being obsessed with it,
I believe in 96 he started going down there to the Congo,
but it's in this really deep,
deep,
deep.
The Congo is giant.
It's like almost as wide as the entire United States and it's just dense jungle.
Like good fucking luck finding what's in there.
Yeah,
I mean,
but that's what you got big foot.
Yeah.
It's the same deference.
You got nobody.
People aren't going,
you get,
and then those who were saying they see them or whatever,
they're doctors,
they're lawyers or conservation officers,
they're hunters,
they're anglers,
they're hikers.
They're not all whack job.
You know,
they're not all whack jobs and you're the one guy when everyone,
everyone goes,
ah,
you know,
it's all bullshit.
Like a damn.
I think less know some shit.
You know when you say that you heard something that sounded like a gorilla and
it's in the,
it's possible.
There's like,
who the fuck's,
he's a wolverine.
Okay,
good luck finding a wolverine.
You could wander around the woods of your whole life and never see a wolverine.
Never see a dead one.
But they're out there.
We know they're out there.
Will you take whatever that is and lessen its population by 90% now you have 10%
of that population and it's smart.
You're going to find that elusive.
Exactly.
60,000 black bears on Ontario.
I've never seen a black bird skeleton.
Yeah.
Oh,
where's the bones?
You know?
Well,
60,000 black and never see a black.
You don't surrender to bones.
Yeah.
Bears eat embarrassed council.
Now if you've got,
let's,
let's say there's 8,000 Sasquatch and Ontario and they're secret and there they
are elusive and they're intelligent,
they're smart,
and they bury their bonds.
It's not going to,
I say eight difficult.
I won't say any of that.
I think if there's any,
there's like,
there's 8,000 you really think is that.
And I don't think there's,
it has to be,
I think this one dude,
ah,
that was there and pointed out on the shows like this 1950s hairdo you,
it's one through the trees.
Right?
In loch ness.
That's bullshit though.
Okay.
That,
that what we saw.
If there is a big foot,
that's not it.
That's bullshit.
Yeah.
It's 100% bullshit.
That guy's a liar.
And it's unfortunate because people like that,
these people that want to make shit up,
they confused the fuck out of everybody who wants to believe.
I think it's also confusing that Pete,
you're,
you're using the word big foot when that's not really what it is.
It's more like finding giant,
you know,
another one,
the big eights
because putting what the original guy that made the big foot name or whatever
this big monster is,
didn't they already find out that it was fake through the whole thing?
Okay,
well no,
that guy didn't make the name.
That's the thing.
That's the,
you're talking about the Patterson footage,
which is no big foot came from turning over the construction equipment and all
the tracks that were found
and that there was a fake gun guy who came out and said,
but when you look at what was done there,
the faker see there's a problem is when the fakers are faking.
You know what I'm saying?
I'm like,
Oh,
I did that hoax out.
That was all me.
It's like,
no,
it wasn't,
man,
you were drunk in Wisconsin at the time.
It had nothing to do with you.
But guys come out and claim to do that and now that really messes up the water
because now you've got someone who's really,
really just try to find out and the hoaxers are our hoaxing,
you know themselves and they didn't actually hoax it.
And,
and that's the stuff that's messed up.
So like the first thing that guy that people point back to that can't remember
the guy's name who had the tracks and show here's his wouldn't track.
She says,
I did those trucks on that time in the 50s with the like,
actually he didn't and he couldn't have pulled off what they found.
Like you would have needed 20 men and major machines and a big conspiracy just
to make a bunch of tracks going up into the bush.
It's not realistic.
That's what I'm,
that's what I'm about a lot is it's the whole thing as well.
It's a hoax.
It's a person that's a hooks.
Hang on a second.
How many people are out in the woods dedicating their life to sticking a
fricking track in the mud in the middle of nowhere in the Sierra Nevadas or the
rocky mountains.
They're not doing it.
Nobody's got time for that shit
better.
A better argument I think,
is that the native Americans had over 200 different names for this thing.
Right.
That's what's more interesting to me because they don't really have a lot of
mythological animals in the native American Lore.
There's not a lot of fake animals.
I mean,
there's a few things that they believe in and they had some weird gods that they
worshiped and you know,
they believe that they could dance and make it run on the birds certain track.
But you know,
the Thunderbirds thing is a weird one too,
man,
because we know that there were certain species of bird that were enormous that
went extinct.
We also know there's a thing called the terror bird that live before the last
ice age,
uh,
went away.
I believe they,
they got him down to like 10,000 plus years ago.
So it was like you're talking about the pleistocene,
right?
You're talking about planning the saber saber tooth tigers existed.
Yeah.
Woolly mammoths.
Well,
they had this fucking bird,
this giant seven foot tall bird that was like predatory,
that would run around and there's one of them called the shoe bill that lives in
the Congo that they think was like,
have you ever seen that thing?
Christ,
you got to see this fucking thing.
This is a what?
A creepy ass bird.
It's called a shoe bill.
It's a five foot tall prehistoric bird with a giant face like a fucking hatchet
in its face.
It's got this giant like huge bill and it's like,
it's,
it catches fish.
This is crazy.
BBC They did on the
Congo.
Look at that God damn thing.
No,
there's a,
there's better ones of it though.
Dick.
There's better ones,
but there's pull up,
uh,
I,
I'm pretty sure it's shoe bill.
Shoe Bill Byrd,
Africa.
There is it below that.
That one right there below it that,
yeah,
that one neuron all the way.
Yeah.
I see the one in the middle.
The one that went to Jack in that bird.
Yeah,
that one.
They were just clicking on that fucking thing.
Look at that thing.
Make that bigger,
jammy.
Look at that goddamn creepy ass animal.
Yeah,
it's killing the duck.
You hate ducks.
Now go back and there's another one in that,
in that a series of images right below that we see that thing face on.
Look at that word.
It's looking at you head on when you see it's bill.
What a creepy fuck that is.
That's a real bird.
What a creepy goddamn dinosaur that thinks five feet tall and it walks around
like a fucking like a fake animal.
Dark crystal and it jacks things in the water.
It's a horrible looking monster.
You already tapped into something.
You're really super right about the whole native American perspective on Big
Foot and all that.
If you go up into Winnipeg and I was up there with them up there,
they've got like their,
you know,
their seven teachings and stuff and they're based on the Raven and the wolf and
the Fox and the bear.
And right in the middle is savvy,
big foot.
And then the Eagle and the audit,
I think it's just like,
it's not like,
oh yeah,
and there's a thunder bird.
There's a mythological this,
no,
it's just seven normal animals.
And in the,
in that span of seven normal animals right in the middle is big foot.
What they consider to be a normal species that's there.
They don't make the difference.
They don't differentiate right now to someone on the subway going,
fuck you Joe Rogan.
I'm shutting this podcast.
Listen to me,
man.
We're not saying the big foot's real.
That's not what I'm saying.
What I'm saying is that God damn animal was definitely real.
We don't know.
What are you saying?
We know that God damn animal [inaudible] was real.
And here's where it's crazy.
It was real in the exact area.
We absolutely know the human beings migrated from,
they migrated from Asia across the Bering strait when it was a landmass.
When you can cross it walking,
they came to North America and where an animal like that would exist would be in
the heavily dense forest of the Pacific northwest was exactly where he would
come across.
They would come across through Alaska to the Pacific northwest,
and that's where you hear about them.
It's,
it doesn't make sense that you would have a real animal that lived in a real
place that you absolutely know existed,
coexisted with human beings that were just like you and I.
We've been in this form,
essentially they s the scientists believe for 250,000 plus years,
so a hundred thousand years ago,
they know this thing lived and they know it lived where people were walking
around and they were walking all the way to America.
So the question is,
are they still there?
That's the question.
One of the things,
the,
another question I'd like to ask,
what do you do with someone who's you respect you admire?
They're normal.
They're saying,
and then they say to you,
look man,
fuck,
I don't care what you think.
I'm just telling you what I saw and I know what I saw.
And that happens a thousand freaking dimes.
People do drugs.
The people that people are delusional,
mass delusion,
like psychotic,
right or not or not.
Or they want you to love them.
So they just want to talk about big foot.
Really,
man.
No,
there's over Mike's House.
These people,
these are people with nothing to gain,
lots to lose,
no money to make.
And in fact half the time you can't even drag the story out of them.
Like I'm like,
okay,
fine.
All right,
I'm going to tell these.
That's like girls who don't pretend they don't want to fuck her
girlfriends.
They will tell you some stuff.
I've never actually done this before.
Don't believe him.
I can't believe I'm doing this well,
how do you know how to do that with my ass?
They know they've been there.
They're liars.
That's an in Georgia.
He's King of the analogy.
Listen man,
I think it's entirely possible that there is an undiscovered primate fascinated
by this.
You wanted,
you were supposed to come out with me though,
not pussy down this one to see a give you some time on your own and you found it
and then if you didn't,
I confirm my suspicions.
Here's the problem,
man.
These guys,
they go looking for it.
They're almost all full of shit and a lot of them are nice guys,
but they're true believers.
They're true believers in a sense where they're not looking at things
rationally,
they're not looking at things objective.
And so that's what I do.
You survivor,
man,
Dennis talking,
it'll pull the truth right out of your bones.
So that's what happened though was survivorman big foot.
Big Foot is I'm saying.
Okay.
All right.
You got big foot and some alien space ships.
Leave me in that valley overnight.
Couple minutes.
Let's see what else.
You've got gigantic mythic goes and a herd of 12 of them.
Okay.
Leave me in the valley.
Let me see it.
Let's cut to the short and curlies.
What?
What have you seen?
What is the craziest Shit that you've seen?
What is the one thing that you've seen that you think you could bring up?
You gotta.
You gotta have to watch the episode.
Fuck Outta here dude.
Knock it up high.
So on,
on one of the episodes.
So here.
All right.
I'm one of the episodes of joint.
Can't believe shut up.
I'm going to tell you so you don't have to watch the episode.
Okay,
so spoiler alert on the episode,
you watch the episode,
we're going to go up to the top of the mountain and radio and everybody hears,
spoiler finding big foot ain't finance shit.
There's a spoiler.
Hey,
if I,
if,
if I had for you the definitive footage,
here it is.
Obviously by now I would've done a press conference.
Exactly.
That's why the foot footage is bullshit right here.
Eat that.
Took a hit of that.
Tell you the truth.
We'll talk to you when you're surviving animal food in plastic and then eat it
and then poop it out and eat it later.
Like I'd take the plastic off and eat it.
Jesus Christ.
It seems like it could work.
That's a technique I've never thought.
I mean,
if you're going to be like on your own for five days,
you can eat a bunch of food,
but wrap it up in plastic and then later poop it out then and take it out with
them.
How would you get the nutrients from the food and the first place when we get to
your stomach,
poop it out and understanding meaning like it and then you poop it out and like
before you leave for your trip,
go to go get stuffed like Boston market or something.
Throw in this where you're poorly thought out ideas and then get a bunch of
plastic.
Don't tell him stop,
can't,
can't tell.
Got to eat his poop.
No,
no,
no.
I'm saying like eat like a big meal before you're about to leave.
And he would eat his own food.
It's called the youth.
It's called second harvest.
And then native Americans,
they maybe take a bunch of like protein bars,
wrap them up in plastic,
eat it,
and then poop it out in a couple of days and then unwrap the plastic they need.
What kind of Shit?
A fucking whole protein bar.
Plastic can make it through your digestive track.
Carry the bars in my backpack and just eat 'em three days later,
porous understanding of the human digestive track ever exhibited on a podcast.
I was trying to figure out what you were saying.
I thought you were saying eating poop.
You're not talking about a little Baggie of heroin that a drug mule and I was
thinking like maybe going to make you survive.
You'll,
you'll get another hour's worth of energy from that little heroin bag.
What about petite fed liaison?
He,
he announces wrapped in plastic.
You're going to die.
People get diverticulitis cause they get a fucking watermelon seeds stuck in
word diverticulitis.
Mayonnaise.
Well Brock Lesnar one from the UFC,
God brought divert diverticulitis,
serious operation when they remove 12 inches of his colon.
Then I found out about it.
I looked into it and I thought it was just because of eating meat,
but Anthony Bordain informed me that you can eat a seed.
Like you get like a sunflower seeds or something stuck inside your tract,
your digestive track and it starts an abscess and you'd get sick.
Yeah,
you could.
You can die from a fucking seed getting stuck.
He's like,
all kinds of stuff gets stuck in there,
so it's not necessarily just protein.
There's also control.
The board game is like a Gi tract doctor now you can't eat a Petite Philemon Yon
Shit it out in the woods,
son.
That's all I'm saying.
You gotta have to have a better strategy than that ever.
I guess I was thinking survivor island,
like trying to find a way to cheat.
You can't,
you can't.
You just carry it in your backpack.
You're pregnant.
If you had enough food for a day,
all the food packed up through your body.
What can a calorie consumption are you thinking you're going to have?
You know,
you got to go on a diet.
That's one thing he could do.
You could get fat as fuck and then go out there and just live off your fat for a
few days.
That would actually work like you would could.
I never ever,
and all of a survivor man shows.
I never ever prepared for the show by either trying to trim down and make my
stomach smaller or by bulking up and having all the extra.
I was figure,
well then that's
not even realistic either.
Whenever I start something,
it's gotta be like,
I just,
you know,
it was going somewhere else and got lost.
You too honest for television and we can't use you anymore.
I know.
That's super pseudoscience channel.
What you just said.
I mean,
that is,
what am I?
I've,
I haven't,
I've been told before it,
you know,
unless that's a bit too earnest.
I'm like,
Oh God,
no.
Let's get back to the short and curlies they want.
Have you seen,
what have you seen at the top of the mountain and radium?
Radium.
Where's that?
Radium Springs.
British Columbia.
First time of my life ever.
That's a big area,
right?
Big highlight.
High Salt.
It's a smaller settings here.
First time ever.
First of all,
I've never,
I've never claimed this.
I saw big freaking lights in the sky.
Couldn't explain.
I'm like looking at what the,
and I'm there.
They are just the whole classic Ufo thing.
It was like,
what the,
never seen anything like that.
I don't,
I don't claim anything like that.
While you were filming the show while I'm on the top of the mountain,
when I'm filming the show,
I'm looking at the big,
these big ass lights way bigger.
If it was a plane,
it was bigger than the Concord and they just hovered there and gone like that.
Just gone.
Then that same night and some other shit happened,
I woke up and I swear I was in my mommy sleeping bag and I swear something was
sitting on top of me and I couldn't move.
I tried to move and it wasn't like,
you know,
you wake up in a half,
half dream Army were sleeping on.
It's like all frozen.
You're like,
oh shit.
A wolf seeding my arm.
Know this was like the arm on top.
Who the fuck has Jane's got wolves eating their arms.
Don't you sleep in the woods alone too much,
man.
That's what's what you dream about when ever dreamed about getting a c,
you got to come on and do one of these shows with me.
You'll dream about wolves eat and your arms to him.
Hopefully.
No,
I don't want that dream.
It's not a good dream.
Yeah.
The problem is that actually can happen if things go horribly wrong.
Wolf can eat your,
I've been surrounded by wolves while you're out there.
I have,
yes,
I have.
Yup.
I've had them.
I can see them.
There's one,
there's another.
And what were they doing?
They were checking in.
Following,
checking you out of topics.
Yeah.
The checkout is a by yourself.
It's scary.
Although many majors,
you know what it better than that.
Not even a week ago today and they had to spend the majority of the night in a
tree because it was a literally not sensationalizing.
This was a man eating tart tiger down below me on the ground.
What?
Like less than a week ago.
India.
Oh my God.
I did my first survivor man.
Shoot in India.
Fuck,
are you doing fuck that noise.
Oh my God.
Where would you like in the sooner pants?
I was,
uh,
up in,
you know,
the Jim Corbett Park area in northern India,
north of Delhi,
uh,
about five hour drive north of Delhi and a into the forest there.
And
I was like,
Oh,
you know,
this area is not that bad.
Last when I got there,
after I was there,
I was told that I was dropped in the densest population of tigers in the world,
royal Bengal,
tiger dense population,
the world.
And then she says to me this,
the Madam and she is,
she goes,
well,
and then the one we have,
uh,
has killed 21 people this year so far,
but it's okay.
She only recently started eating the corpses and like,
you gotta be kidding me.
And they told me this after I got out and then I saw a tiger on the first night.
On the second night I heard a growl.
I had to go up into a tree and I spend a majority of the night and I'm,
that's all filmed.
Like I'm filming myself for Survivorman.
I got the whole selfie thing going on and I'm like,
all right.
And I had to like pull my camera up with a rope and I'm holding the camera and
I'm like,
okay,
I'm starting not in sleep,
but just sat and waited and waited and see.
That to me is so much more interesting than that bullshit monkey fake.
That's real shit and big foot.
Yeah,
I know.
That's real shit.
I mean that's a real animal.
I mean if there was a big foot and there was also a tiger,
okay,
if these,
absolutely.
We're real thing that,
that,
I put that up on my Twitter the other day.
That's a classic video.
Somebody tweeted it to me and it just,
it's the one thing I'm the most afraid of actually is tigers territory.
But show that again,
Jamie,
this is a video.
We're looking at their posts,
folks who are just listening to this video of this tiger flying through the air
and attacking this guy who's on this elephant.
He's sitting on the top of the elephant and the tiger just decides,
fuck this dude.
And he jumps up through the air fly.
It's lucky he didn't get gored by the,
by the bull elephant with the tusks.
Well,
he get the,
well,
the elephant didn't want to have nothing to do with that fucking cat,
but the,
um,
the guy got fucked up when that thing clauses army tore his arm apart.
Those are razorblades end to be super powerful Predator.
That's what was basically 70 yards away from me.
Man.
I can't believe you didn't like fully researched this.
I thought I did.
It's like what are the worst fucking camping ideas ever?
When you go to India,
you renegotiate everything you do every hour.
Every hour is a new renegotiation.
Really?
How so?
We're going to have like,
this person's going to be,
they're going to lead you in an hour later.
So this person's not here,
but we're going to my buddy,
my cousin's going to lead you in an hour later.
My cousin couldn't make it.
And when you can't,
you're not allowed to go in any way because the government says it's just like
every hour was going like that.
So get this.
I go out and probably think you're crazy.
They do think you're nuts.
So I went out to do my first night of survivor man alone.
I'm out in the jungle,
I'm out there.
And,
um,
I'm like,
I'm feeling myself.
all right.
You know,
when you have to do a zoom,
probably doing to stay here and stay here for the night sort of thing.
Get a fire going and doing the whole thing.
I hear some noise and I,
and I,
I go back about four or 500 yards and,
and in the middle of the jungle,
the debt,
the fucking forest 50 people show up and have a Lord Shiva Rave.
And all of a sudden I hear
[inaudible]
and I'm literally,
so I'm in the middle of the forest surviving right now.
Wow.
It was the most bizarre thing.
And it turns out this
one time of the whole year in this remote little place where there's this stone
in the forest is the Lord Shiva stone.
All these people,
like 50 people on motorcycles showed up.
And I'm like,
so I'm gonna,
I'm gonna walk deeper that way.
Cause there's tigers and at least they're quiet.
And you know what's really bizarre is that there's a big push to save the tiger
in India is a big push to make sure that the murders of humans have healthy
populations,
whereas scare,
we don't want them to go away.
Now come on.
It's weird.
Those are weird.
I'm not saying that we should encourage extinction because they are,
even though they're well,
are terrifying and they're predatory and they're dangerous.
They're a beautiful,
amazing life form.
I mean,
I don't want tigers to go extent.
I don't want to be anywhere near them,
but I don't want them to go extinct because I think they're fascinating.
They're great.
They're fast hot.
Then you don't go camping where they eat,
so you just,
now that's a thing.
It's like you got to allow the tiger to be the tiger.
If you go and you sleep in an area that's rich with polar bears are tigers and
you have a tiger,
a polar bear problem,
right?
It's like,
well,
why am I having this issue with polar bears because you're sleeping in polar
bear territory,
idiot.
Like isn't this their world?
There's an issue
area in the India called the cinder bands,
and there's an issue with the water because the water is like got too much salt
in it.
So the animals that irritated all the time,
and there's a lot of typhoons in that area.
So the,
a lot of people die and they get washed into the river and the Tigers develop a
taste for human flesh.
So it's one of the rare places where they're actively hunting people on a
regular basis.
And the last two months it's not that rare.
No,
it's not right at all.
I just got,
I sang,
she got back from India lesson five,
six days ago.
It's not,
the tiger attacks are normal.
Super Common.
They're normal.
So their,
their way of life,
they're thinking about what life is.
It's so different than us at any moment.
They get snatched away by a monster.
At any moment you're walking from a lake or a river to your family in a hut and
you hear a twig snap and you turn and you see this 800 pound thing already in
the air on it's way to you.
And they know that's a wraps on [inaudible] deputy.
That's all folks life in the Bush and life in the jungle,
man.
You feel that fucking blade slice into your juggler crushed down your vertebrae?
I'd wear deodorant.
Were to blame.
Yeah.
He set up a new word.
It's the word of God displayed.
Now's not the time for grammar.
Talking about it.
We're singing can do somewhat correct their grammar.
You slept in a fucking tree.
Yields stayed up there in a tree.
No.
When do you feel confident enough to climb?
Fuck.
All right.
So you know why I knew the tiger was there.
The monkeys started going crazy.
The peacock started going crazy.
They all,
they all react.
They're all like,
Holy Shit.
And they,
all the monkeys go up high and they're like,
wow.
Right.
And you know,
and you're looking and you know,
nothing's going on over there.
There's been,
there's a tiger slowly moving through.
You don't hear any twig.
Snap for a tag and you see it.
I saw it.
Yeah,
I saw it on the,
uh,
the night before.
I saw it go across the field that night.
I didn't see it.
I heard it growl,
which was even scarier.
Oh my God.
The monkeys all saw it.
They were all so ain't get so,
and you have to be,
and he's 12 feet up the tree because they can,
they can jump and kind of reach up to 12 feet.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
There's a video of messed up.
There's a video of them,
uh,
attacking some meat.
They A,
they hold it up in the air and the Tigers leap up to get it and you watch it.
You like,
what is that possible that can really pull that video up.
Damien is the most ridiculous video.
This is guy who holds this meetup and this tiger just does something that you
just,
you'd go,
oh,
I kind of like,
I never internalized what it looks like when they jump 12 feet in the air.
Like why watch this?
They hold this meetup,
look at this thing,
this thing fucking,
that spring flies and grab its head is like 14 feet in the air.
That's why I climbed at least 12 feet up the tray.
My God,
watch that again.
That's insane.
That animals,
just what it can do with its body to kill things.
I mean it's,
that's what it's designed for,
but the fact that they're sitting there,
these two giant cancer sitting there watching this person feed them like what
Ah,
bizarro world is that has just a bit tuition,
their fence,
they're fenced in and this guy is holding this thing in a crane up in the air
and the tiger jumps up and grabs it.
It's insane.
They're powerful man.
Now you don't have web kit and you can,
no,
I didn't crack.
There was an area I was in and uh,
they use the force.
They do of course forces always there.
They wouldn't let me go into an area without an armed guard,
armed guard.
I was like,
Oh dude,
I'm like,
survivor,
man,
I've got to go out.
I got to do this thing and then I've got to be alone.
We do not tell the truth to that.
And,
and I wasn't allowed to be out there without it,
without an armed guard.
So they had land.
I was like maybe half a half a maybe a quarter mile away was like actually pair
of armed guards on either cloud.
While I know whack his guards cause you to be like three feet away.
I'm thinking if this thing 75 yards from Maine and pounces on me,
how fast are you going to get here?
Miles.
A long time.
It takes a long time to get and here's on foot from a quarter of what it does.
Yeah.
How fast can you run a mile?
Like a really fast mile is like a four minute mile.
Right?
That's like the thing that no one thought you could ever do.
So one fourth of that one is a minute.
So stop and think about that on a track.
Yeah,
but,
but just stop and think about a minute of running.
That's what it is.
If you're the like the fastest guy ever,
you run for a minute to get to you to flip the fuck a tiger can do to you.
And why met 89885750650 five you're fucking torn to show rads.
It's like you with a roach,
like literally as for Roche,
as you had terror,
roaches,
body apart.
That's what a tiger could do to you.
It's insane.
The powerful and you're sleeping about or hanging out in a tree above it and of
course you're not going to,
I'm going to give a super shot out.
The fact that they're actually 30% increasing in population in this one area,
which is phenomenal because they are beautiful,
so awesome.
I think there's enough powerful,
beautiful now 72 of them and make sure they fuck,
we need more,
actually need more of them.
Jesus fall on.
I went more.
Sure.
Yeah.
It seems like there's more big foot than there are than there are tigers.
Oh,
well I don't know about that because I've seen a tiger.
I've,
I've seen it with my own eyes at the zoo.
You in this big foot thing.
What if they dropped off one tiger a year in Los Angeles,
but they don't tell you where it's at.
Well,
they kind of have mountain lions wandering around.
They usually don't fuck anybody up.
I got to get this guy out just like out in the bush.
No,
you know,
no,
you need to like have like some shit that's not fake.
Like that guy with his monkey face.
Well you know my shits not fake.
So your shit is not.
Say you wouldn't fake anything.
If I was going to,
and I remember I texted you,
said you went,
I'm shooting the big shows,
you want to come up,
I would take you out and I would,
I would,
I'd find this.
I said,
this is where they say all this shit happens.
We'd go,
we sit up,
we shipped by the fire with the case again when we drink and we,
and we keep the fire gone step all night.
And then in the morning it's like that three o'clock in the morning shit was
insane or well that was nothing.
We told a lot of stories and now I'm really tired.
Yeah,
I get it,
man.
I just hate feeling like an asshole.
And if I was out there wandering around looking for bigfoot and I found out,
I put that I of been at home with my kids.
I could have been writing jokes.
I could have been working out,
I could have been,
you know,
doing something smart.
Eh.
How about like survivor man,
myrtle beach or
we're trying to find bikers.
Can we find them survivorman spring break.
I can be like in a bar trying to build shelters at a bar stools.
What is it that we need to find this fucking thing?
Like if you really stop and think about like how amazing killer whales are and
we know that there are real animal that you can go observe.
They speak in this crazy language.
They don't understand that we don't understand.
Rather they have these families,
they stay with these pods for life.
They're very close to each other.
They have different dialects.
They started observing the sounds at one group makes and it's different from the
sounds.
Another group at another part of the world makes it like they're amazing.
Like they're way more fat.
They kill sharks,
man.
They kill dolphins.
They eat dolphins,
like they're ruthless,
but they're also beautiful and they're really fucking smart.
They're really smart.
I get a weird,
crazy way that just doesn't jive with our idea of,
you know,
like,
oh he doesn't know how to play poker.
Fuck them.
You know,
he doesn't know how to drive a car.
He's a pussy.
He's an idiot.
He was.
You have some weird
crazy life in the ocean intelligence.
They have intelligence where it's applicable in their environment.
They don't need to know how to type.
Okay.
They don't know how to speak Spanish.
They don't have to.
No one Spanish underwater.
They speak dolphin and they speak well.
They know all that shit.
So I,
bigfoot big foot is like,
if it was real,
he's like,
what is he doing?
He's knocking on blood and shit hanging out there,
hiding his shit to hiding his logs.
Melik find bigfoot shit.
He could find bear shit.
You won't find bear bodies.
But if you're telling me you know,
five bear shit,
it's cause you're going to place it doesn't have any bear.
Right.
Where's the big foot shit?
He's burying it,
man.
That's his big trick.
He doesn't save surfers.
He doesn't,
uh,
you know,
kill we've ever seen like,
like a killer whale demonstrate to its young how to kill a seal.
They show them how to kill it.
They get them up on IFE shell I shelves.
They took the,
I know bells and have them slide out,
you know,
big foot's not taking his dog know that he's not.
But we do have any footage.
We have no evidence,
but we have all this evidence of these amazing killer whales that not only that
they're smart as shit and they don't,
we kill them.
They know we killed them and they still talk to us.
They know we killed them.
They have to know by now if they really communicate and they can express,
I mean they might not totally get it or their concept of life and death might be
really weird,
like way different than ours is.
It's,
it's real possible.
But they're so nice to us.
I killed her wheels.
Don't kill people.
They're not attacking surfers.
They're not fighting back because they found out that how they got this thing
and see.
No,
the ones that are in seaworld fight back.
no.
There's been other ones out in the wild.
They don't go attack people has been some rogue stories for sure.
I'll punch up at her,
sees who got,
she got chest bumped by a big fucking killer whale.
Nobody get eaten and nobody came back with no legs.
That it's not what they do.
You know?
And that's an amazing real life animal.
And if we found out the big foot was real and we go,
oh wow.
It's like a big Orangutang but it walks on two legs.
That ain't shit compared to a killer whale.
It's not shit.
It's a would knock an asshole who hides his shit.
That's what it is.
It's a good point.
What you're basically saying is you're wasting your time up there in the woods.
No where the guy who's wearing a rubber mask.
Okay.
I could be at least half a girl,
big foot,
big foot titties on your season finale and that,
and the Patterson footage.
That's what it is.
A female you haven't seen.
It's so real.
It's got teddy.
Do you not know about?
Um,
big foot come to me like these,
these big foot erotica novels that were published on amazon.com.
Okay.
You come to big foot,
I think it's called come to big foot.
Jamie CV had pulled up.
This title became a huge bestseller apparently in this PC world that we live in,
in this weird world of sanitized language and social justice warriors,
there's still women out there that want to get fucked by the biggest monkey.
They can find her fetish,
man big.
It's not a hair fetish.
She saw primate fetish like they want to get gorilla fuck by something that
doesn't even speak their language.
And there's women that are into this idea of Orotic [inaudible] obviously
totally in the fantasy.
I'm not saying they really want to get fucked by these guys,
but I'm saying there,
most of
these men,
these are these things sell.
So there's women that have a fantasy of actually getting fucked by a Sasquatch,
by a giant,
just like just overwhelming.
It just takes you,
ah,
oh that these women have this.
They actually have a fantasy of getting fucked by something that can't talk to
them.
It doesn't have any morals.
It doesn't have any ethics.
Oh,
tell me,
come for big fight.
Virginia Wade.
You're awesome.
I love it.
I hope it's,
I hope it's parody.
Um,
but I hope it's not too,
I hope it's not the stories.
Look,
man,
we don't know.
Look,
this is shit the guys liked.
The girls can't figure out.
Why should we be able to figure out that the soon women that really want to get
fucked by big foot and even if it's only 10 of them,
what if there's a lot of women that are listening right now?
You fucking asshole.
You don't understand.
Women.
Women don't want to get fucked.
No listens my friend.
You don't want I want,
I said,
sweetie,
you don't want to get fucked by bigfoot.
I'm arguing with a person.
It's not even real.
You don't want to get fucked by big foot,
but there's women too.
Or at least they want to read about it.
It might not be.
Look,
there's some guys that are into dressing like mascots and having sex with other
men that that's a real thing.
Okay.
There's some people that are going to be into getting fucked by big foot.
It's not a bad thank God dammit Mrs. Anderson from Harry and the Hendersons.
Yeah.
Well look at that.
The thing was living with the family,
how do you think that thing was going to go down?
How long is he going to tolerate that guy just banging that check.
When is someone going to bring in a female big foot to satisfy him?
Whereas there does the,
do we have rub,
rub maps for a big thing?
Yeah.
Same thing.
Just No.
Yeah.
If you got to have a big foot,
you better find a fucking female big foot for him cause otherwise the reason why
he's come down to the village and she's tired of looking for females.
Hey man,
you already alluded to the whole native American thing and there are lots of
stories and native American Lore of the native women being scooped up,
picked up.
And then there's a lot of dudes doing admit their chick ran off with another
dude.
So they make up some shit about big foot stealing their woman because this is
the manliest man around like,
oh,
could she look at my most offensive native American accent?
Oh Gosh.
She go off with other men.
Must be Sasquatch.
Oh it must be a big foot.
Come down.
Fuck my woman.
Cause I know man could compete with my hog.
That's probably what happened.
That's probably some,
excuse me.
What it sounded like.
It's like a fish story,
you know,
dude,
I almost,
I had to act the boat.
It was at least a hundred pounds bigger than the world back exaggerating.
I had
her in my tp.
Yeah,
no seriously.
Big Foot stole her from the tip of my deck,
my,
you know,
touch her clit and then she shot out like shoes in the matrix.
Like she was a tight rubber fans.
She went flying through the air.
Only.
You only you could have taken this to this place.
It was on this place because this is in this place of fantasy because until
there's a photo of big foot until there's DNA.
That makes sense.
I had that guy,
Todd,
this hotel who's a biologist from the,
um,
I think,
uh,
Nyu.
It's Nyu.
Um,
he's in New York City.
Very,
very brilliant guy.
And he was also on that spike show where they went with Dean Cain.
He went looking for bigfoot.
I didn't watch our show.
I can't watch them anymore.
But talking to that dude,
like,
he's like,
no one's brought in anything man.
There's not one piece of DNA.
And he explained how all this stuff gets contaminated.
Like when you have someone pick something up and they put it in the bag and the
hand to someone,
oh,
it's some sort of human DNA.
You can't do that because someone touched it.
And when people touch things,
you leave DNA on shit.
You know when you're sweaty ass picks up some hairs in the woods and you drop
them into it,
but you're not supposed to touch that with your body.
If you do,
you've contaminated it.
You should have rubber gloves on,
you should have tongs and you should have a direct chain of custody between
touching that fucking thing and that being in a laboratory and being analyzed.
And if you don't,
your studies are bullshit.
And this guy explained this to me in no uncertain terms.
And when you look at it that way,
you go,
okay,
that means none of it's real.
Like not no one's found anything.
They've never found a bone.
They never found a piece of hair.
They'd never found big foot shit.
They never found one thing that you could say,
this makes big foot a real animal.
So all you're going on his stories and all you're going on is the knowledge that
an animal like that used to exist and the knowledge that they found another
unknown primate and the island of Flores that was only 10,000 plus years ago,
I think like maybe 13,000 years ago.
It's in that range,
which is incredibly recent,
like really,
really,
really recent for a three foot tall little monkey person.
You know that use tools but had a small brain like you imagine those things for
one and around today.
Weird Little Freaky fucking half monkey people.
Cool.
Oh,
it'd be so scary though.
They'd probably steal your baby and eat it.
It's such a feminist.
A fuck though.
Ooh,
you live fucking,
wouldn't you?
Yes.
Come for tiny Sasquatch.
Hobbit.
People home for the Orang.
Pendek.
It doesn't have the same sort of rhyme to,
it doesn't have you read.
It's called have you ever fucked an animal before you gay?
Easy Dude.
Before what?
Before you ate it,
you didn't see that the outtakes.
That's not,
listen,
this is not alone in that woods and they went looking.
This sounds like a confession is what I'm thinking.
Let's get back to big foot.
Okay.
What is the one thing you've done the show or you had your experience outside
the show and then you went and did the show.
What is the one thing while were on the show
that really gave you pause?
It really made you think we were videotaping?
Uh,
trigger motion.
Yeah.
Motion triggered camera had the all set up,
put bait out like it's a big foot type thing.
Put Bait out and watched from one clip to the next clip,
the Bait,
all of it to chocolate bars in an apple in a WildFit,
a frame field disappear.
Just disappear.
It's on the show.
I have no answer for that whatsoever.
A mouse would have said this is a really sensitive half second triggers.
A mouse would have set that off and beside that had like many,
many feet.
Can it be paused?
Oh,
I posit in the show because it can it be paused?
Like could someone walk up to it and shut its operation off momentarily?
Go over there,
grab a candy bar,
walk out of frame and then turn it back on.
That's not possible.
No,
it's not possible.
Why isn't it possible it doesn't work that way or is it I was alone.
I was on the top of a mountain.
Not,
I'm not saying I'm the top of the I.
Is it possible in this circumstance?
Is it possible with the operation of that trail?
Because what happens is no,
it's not.
Not because to,
to turn the camera off,
right.
You have to open it up the second you move up here,
you're not being filmed.
Okay.
I had another scene where a black bear actually came and took my,
took my camera and it's all on camera.
You see his mouth biting the Lens.
You see him pull the camera off the tree is,
he's walking.
You can kind of see the area of his limb just moving as he's walking.
And a lot of those you can set up to send the data to Wifi.
Right?
You can't actually.
Yeah.
And some of them will send you like text messages when they have images.
When they see something,
they see movement.
They'll send you a text message that alerts you that you have movement on your
camera's.
Yeah.
So you didn't get any of those readings,
but you did get the candy bars disappearing.
Disappearing to think the bright lights in the sky stole your candy.
I don't know,
maybe how much,
what did you think happened for real?
For Real.
I can't,
I haven't got a freaking clue.
Is it infrared camera?
Yes it is.
It's so,
it would be a crazy coincidence if the cameras malfunctioned at the exact moment
that someone came along and stole the candy.
That doesn't,
that's impossible.
It's impossible.
But is there a way to the top of a mountain,
but if say some hoaxer dude knew you were going and was slick about it and was
like real,
like stealthy,
not most likely.
Not Possible.
Most likely.
But is it possible,
is there a device that you could use that would freeze the operation of the
camera?
Is there some sort of a magnetic field that you could maybe generate something
powerful that would cause it to disrupt momentarily enough where you could run
over and grab the candy if you are big foot only if you make fun,
how come?
Only if your big foot not,
oh,
I didn't say only.
Okay.
If your big foot I said every big well that means at the end of the show when I
wrap it up I say,
I don't have an answer for this.
Right.
The skeptics would say everything fell off the branches and out of the field of
view before the camera could register the falling,
even though they were stuck on things up.
Right.
Like this and it's infrared.
Wait a minute.
They were hanging.
They weren't just sitting down so they were stuck on the guess branches.
Okay.
Would a camera be sensitive enough to depict a cause?
You catch that if a candy bar fell off a branch,
it seems like not a large enough object fell off on its own.
I think it could potentially fall out of frame.
The problem is these things were all stuck and lodged.
There was zero wind,
but yeah,
but isn't it more likely that gravity pulled them down the ground and the big
foots and visible and knows how to shut off cameras?
Oh,
does that question,
what am I a scientist?
Yes,
you are.
Yes.
Is the answer to that.
I need a lab coat that's more like actually who could answer that question more
likely.
Probably a scientist more like someone who's not.
What do they measure?
What probability are they measuring?
My likely,
well the hell knows what's more likely is what we know exists and it's something
called gravity.
We know that that's a fair enough thing and we know something's hanging on a
tree.
Look,
I've set up things,
think they're going to be there to the end of the time.
When it came back a week later,
they were gone crazy on things like that happen.
Gravity always went and that's possible.
Works on tits.
It works on balls.
It works on candy bars falling off the trees.
Nobody wins.
Gravity always wins.
So,
and I think that if it's between gravity and an unknown monkey,
I'm going to go with gravity.
You watch a show while definitely watch it now you got to see it but sounds
crazy though.
It's just like dad is crazy,
but that's it.
That's not just candy bars disappearing.
That's the number one thing I tried it.
It is possible that you try to recreate.
Did you like try to set some candy bars up and like put a timelapse on him or
put the trail cam on them rather and see if you create it and weren't able to
recreate it because it didn't fall.
Did you try to make it fall like put it up like real flimsy and then knock them
down and see if the camera picks it up?
No,
that's what I would have done because if the camera didn't pick it up,
I go,
well there it is.
It fell right.
But wasn't there.
But then again it fell from what I mean it'd be like if I put that there,
he told me what the odds are of this falling off of this table before tomorrow
morning.
Well that's different,
but that's not setting it on a stump.
Right.
Like setting this that the analogy of the comparisons are saying it.
They were firmly put in places where they wouldn't just fall.
Right.
So they were put in places where they were hanging,
put in places.
Okay.
I'm confused.
I thought you were saying they were hanging from a tree,
which you picked up.
You said hanging?
I never,
I'm sorry.
I was,
I thought you said they dropped out of frame.
Which dean w I was thinking there were,
you said they were stuck in place.
I thought you meant like there was a branch or something like one,
one apple.
I was like,
like there's the brands stock brands like this.
Okay.
So it was,
but it was stuck inside the branch,
but it was still like hanging in the air.
Like the branch.
It was the apple was hanging in the air on the ground.
I would say no to that.
No.
What was it on the ground?
No,
it was 15 feet up.
Okay.
But in the branch 15 feet up,
I don't want to get bogged down in semantics.
People go,
what's the point?
Um,
if it was in the air is 15 feet above the ground.
Right.
And the apple stuck on the branch,
it could conceivably a fallen off.
It's nothing like being on this table.
Being on this table is 100% likely that if you put this lighter here in 24
hours,
as long as we don't have an earthquake,
the lines,
or at least we'll be splitting hairs,
but I'll give you that.
That's not splitting hairs at all.
We're talking about something that could fall from gravity versus something that
absolutely cannot move unless some interfering force comes along.
No road.
Well,
the two chocolate,
but ferocious wind and earthquake could chocolate bars?
No,
this is the same chocolate bars.
We're sitting here in the middle of the table.
There was,
okay,
so they were stuck on tree branches.
This bag and the chocolate bar sitting right like that.
Right.
Nice.
And like not going anywhere.
Okay.
So for folks who that he's making his hand like about 16 inches,
Brian's Dick and inside as take a pen,
which is my dick,
small black.
It's of happy Dick.
No,
it's nothing to brag about.
Um,
so okay,
so that little tiny baby dick in between the both space,
that's where you,
uh,
that's where you dropped a candy bar.
Right?
And so the apple stuck in a tree but 15 feet off the ground.
And then the candy bars,
candy bars.
Now what parts of the carer anymore?
Anyway,
I do.
I live in America or we were free with as candy does.
Are they called?
Yeah,
exactly.
I Dunno.
Chocolate,
chocolate.
Hell,
it's a Kansas trying to confuse us man.
We got him on the run here.
It was dry out really fast.
If you ever let an apple out,
like if it has a little key,
it turns Brown logic and your science just stop [inaudible] sound this mysticism
to be uncovered here now.
Um,
the candy bars,
you left them on the log.
So the candy bar is represented by the baby Dick.
Right.
And uh,
so this,
this is flat.
It's sitting on a flat surface.
What it kind of an area we're looking at,
we're looking at like a heavily wooded area.
Is that what it's like?
Top of the mountain?
Sparse trees,
rocks,
uh,
rodents got road and sometimes for sure.
Right.
Um,
wouldn't it be likely that maybe a road and is small enough that it could grab
that candy bar?
And maybe the trail cameras set up for like game probably set up for something
that triggers it's it's camera sensors.
No,
in fact it,
we showed it with the testing that it actually triggers with dust in the air.
Just always be on,
oh,
this testing
things,
dust.
You remember those scenes and twilight where the sunlight is cutting through the
trees and you see all the dust in the air,
all the glistening stuff and shit and birds.
So it'd be a constant like flash.
It'd be like a movie basically.
And that's what happened.
It was constantly,
you could run it together like stop animation.
There's just nothing would stop,
would keep moving.
So good pickup dust.
All right,
so the bold,
my growing up,
I know where you're going with this like no,
no,
I agree with my theory is the road that theory does the only one that makes
sense to me,
unless a big foot can fuck with cameras and make them stop.
Is that what you were implying?
That's what I was implying.
It really for real,
for real.
I was implying I didn't say it.
That's what it was.
But you will implying the possibility.
You will put that in your what if folder.
What if because that
that's what this better be good.
It's aliens.
I'm not even,
I'm sorry.
I'm not telling you.
Come on.
We got to joke around with drinking and we have a little Guinness,
a little marijuana.
We're talking big foot.
You can't take this seriously.
Sorry.
Um,
so if it is possible that this animal exhibits some strange power over
electronics like that would,
that would
explain a lot of things,
right?
Who explained a lot of shit?
Like how come there's no pictures of bigfoot?
Funny thing.
Funny thing,
we found out that it knows how to stop cameras.
It's smart enough to figure out how to stop cameras.
Not Smart enough or pants or shoes or any cool shit.
No cell phones driving a car.
Nope,
no big foot TV.
But they figured out how to stop cameras cause a,
that fucking camera is a problem.
Soon as man invented the camera,
they saw it and were like,
we gotta we gotta figure it out and we got a screech.
It's the Howells Howell's killer camera.
Did you do the how?
That was a big,
of course they do the hoop,
the,
does anybody know what it sounds like?
That's what I said.
I didn't even know what you're saying.
It'd be like pissing and he'd say,
Oh man,
dude,
you guys are ugly.
You don't know what you're saying.
You call him for some Dick.
That's the worst.
When you get there.
He thinks you're a dick.
Tease just beats the shit out of you.
Oh,
horny.
Bigfoot wasting his time.
It's like you don't want to be a fake bigfoot Tinder.
You know what I'm saying?
Tinder big foot pick.
Yeah.
That's what they use.
10 kids today.
The kids today,
they felt could just be people from the future fucking with us.
Easily.
Much more likely than bigfoot.
I think time travel,
it's more believable.
What's more believable is the aliens went back in time,
grabbed the gigantic tow Pythagoras and just drop it off periodically in the
woods to fuck with people.
That's more likely than a large more than tigers.
Population of gigantic Pythia start running through the woods.
You're going to love this one.
It gets even better.
Another.
On another occasion.
It was all about the potential of it being the nephron from the Bible.
Genesis chapter six
number the chapters.
It gives a lot of credence to words.
It sounds authoritative.
So there you go.
That's the stuff you start hearing and seeing over and over and over again.
It's bizarre.
It's a,
it's a slippery slope.
Is there easily could have been large people at one point in time?
I mean,
there's large people today.
The idea that this has never happened before.
You never had Shaquille O'Neal's before.
You never had that guy from China,
which isn't what's the guy's named gigantic,
gigantic basketball player.
Yeah,
man.
Thank you.
As a giant.
He's so fucking tall.
He's taller than Shaquille O'Neal and like seven ten seven 11 or something.
How tall was he,
Jamie?
Seven seven.
What the fuck?
So that guy exists today.
It's very likely that at one point in time in history there,
there was a batch of those people.
There's a lot of them.
It's souls.
So possible we very aligned and we're not genetically that much different than
people that live 50,000 plus years ago.
So you're talking about the Bible,
which was maybe written somewhere around like four or 5,000 years ago,
and I think the Dead Sea Scrolls,
I think they got that to like,
it was not like 5,000 years,
whatever it is.
So it's anyway,
it's between like what did we have today,
2015 and the last like whatever thousand years.
It's super possible that there was a group of huge fucking Yao Mings running
around back then.
Totally possible.
That's the same genes.
I mean the v they,
they probably have more access to protein and food today,
but if they lived in a really rich source like this,
you know as well as anybody that any bear that lives in an area where there's a
lot of salmon.
Look how tall that guy is.
Oh my God.
Who is that guy is the newest giant.
He's 75 he's a college player now mama do Mgi or something.
I'm like,
oh my God,
he's still growing.
Yeah,
he's only like 19 guys fucking Christ.
Now imagine if you're as short as me.
I'm five eight and I stumbled through it.
And by the way,
back in like the civil war days,
those guys were smaller than me.
Those guys were tiny.
Let's say the average size of a grown man in the civil war was like 135 pounds.
They were these tiny little people that didn't get a lot of food.
Voyagers are the same.
They used to carry like a hundred pounds on her back.
And if you found a guy like this,
if you went to some place and you saw people like this and you got an a boat and
sailed across the sea,
and the land is on an island,
it was filled with legit giants.
Goddamn,
you'd have some stories.
I think that makes more sense.
A big foot.
The nephilim.
So the best thing you saw was nothing.
The best thing you saw was shit disappearing.
Best thing I saw.
Yeah,
it was shit disappearing.
Shit does pay.
But what about sounds?
Did you hear anything?
Did you hear any moans or I need grunts before the odd,
you know,
but what the hell is that?
That could be a bird,
right?
Your gravy.
A Raven frog.
It could be fraud.
It could be Amazon.
Whoop frogs make a lot of crazy noises.
They whoop now.
They make it sound like that for sure.
And he scream or what was the sound that you heard when you were in your tent?
You heard a Sasquatch.
Would you say you're talking about
the survivor man in Alaska show?
Yes.
What does the side,
what does it sound like?
Well,
first of all,
picture the scene.
I'm,
I'm there.
Let me take my pants off.
Middle of nowhere.
Sorry.
Hang on.
Do you like this?
Should be some hand cream over that.
I don't need that shit.
I'll dry jack on.
My man won't be dependent on lotion like some pussy.
It took them.
I don't take painted like a bus.
Let's second.
They just go down like down the hill.
It's got way better.
Okay.
Sorry.
So picture of scene.
Middle of nowhere.
Laska and coast by myself.
What do I smell like?
Lavender.
Sorry.
Okay.
Middle of nowhere.
Alaska coast.
I'm sorry.
I want it to feel I'm filming a scene.
Survive man.
Seen,
blah,
blah.
Just begun to grasp at or something.
And then all of a sudden night,
the trees,
50 yards away at about 10 foot,
12 foot height.
Just start like shaking,
just going crazy.
And then I hear a great day.
Ooh,
Ooh.
Like that.
Only way,
way,
way louder.
Deeper.
Right.
Goes right through your body when it's done.
The problem is I'm in Alaska,
so unless there's an escaped,
great eight from the zoo.
What Dal is that?
Cause bears don't do that.
The skeptics would say that the bear you just ran across a bear that made some
unusual noises five times in a row and then when he left five times in a row,
five times in a row and then when he left,
the whole forest just erupted with breaking trees as it ran away.
I don't know.
I don't know many bears that do that.
Hence my question.
What was that wish I knew these people think it's big foot.
I'm going to go find it.
Indian rave.
No,
there's no way whatsoever that you were asleep before this happened.
Oh,
it was two o'clock in the afternoon.
Two o'clock in the afternoon roughly.
Just so you had more than one experience,
right.
Cause there was another one when you went for your camera and it ran off.
Right.
Dow that was that one.
That was just that.
We know what that was at night.
Did I screw it up?
I'm going to screw it up mid day.
Mid Day.
Okay.
So when,
when you,
you didn't see anything,
you just heard it as,
see it hurts.
To this day I haven't seen anything until I can't claim anything.
I haven't seen it.
That's why I keep saying to show it to him.
He said so a fucked up thing about people telling you stories.
I had it in my head that this was a story at nighttime.
I had it in my head that you were in your tent and then this thing came out at
nighttime and made all this noise and then you went for your camera and ran off
until you,
you know,
you want it to be more like that.
Yeah.
I want it to be smooth.
I didn't have a tent.
It's nighttime scares me and it was midday.
No tent mid day.
Yeah.
It was just,
it was the survivor man thing.
If you haven't seen something where you're like,
that might be big foot,
never seen anything.
Nope.
Nothing.
It's why I want to know finding schizophrenia.
I don't think it's schizophrenia.
I think here's a,
here's a problem.
Heightened states.
Okay.
Heightened
states of fear,
heightened states of a alien nation,
unusual states of the mind,
which uh,
would definitely coincide with being alone in Alaska by yourself with like a
fucking bottle opener and a roll of duct tape and a condom.
I mean that's what you have when you go to these fucking places.
You go and you bring like a bag of shit that you might ordinarily have on you if
something went horribly wrong and you found yourself in these places and then
you figure out a way to survive.
That's a heightened state,
right?
So anything that happens is going to be suspect.
Yeah.
There was some stuff going on in your brain,
man.
Your brain is protecting you from all sorts of weird possibilities.
Bears and predators.
Who knows the fuckers out there and people fucking person the middle of nowhere
like that.
That's,
that might be the most dangerous shit you come across.
Yeah.
That's Timothy Mcveigh running cross big mother fucker out there and it was some
crazy unibomber Ted Kaczynski type character.
That's scarier than the tiles.
Way Scarier than the Tigers.
A guy living by himself.
If you went in deep,
deep,
deep into the woods like miles and miles and hours and hours of hiking and you
found a cabin,
you better not knock on that fucking door.
You just better not.
Who's this guy?
Why is he out here with no one around him?
That guy is crazy.
You don't,
that might be the scariest thing you could ever find in the woods.
A person who lives in the woods.
Yeah,
I totally agree.
I've always said that people go on about the romanticism of some dude living out
in the Bush by himself for 35 years.
It was like,
he's nuts.
Guy's an asshole.
Guaranteed.
It's going to live where there's no people.
Why an asshole?
People are my favorite thing.
I love people.
Why would you live with is no people.
What kind of a foot square piece of shit wants to live in a bloodshed in the
middle of nowhere.
Somebody wants to blow everybody up.
It's like that Ted Kaczynski guy.
That's how he lived it.
Guy Was a professor at Berkeley decided to just move to the woods.
That was his house.
Look at that.
That's scary.
Fuck yeah,
man.
If you see that thing,
light it on fire,
it's scary to take your chances to take a chance of escaping from the flames.
Light that house on fire.
Fuck,
that guy.
Looks like Ohio,
by the way.
I don't mean that.
If you listen to his podcasts right now in a tiny little shed in the middle of
nowhere,
this has always been my dream,
man.
You're shitting on my dream.
I don't really mean that.
I'm just talking really relaxed,
sweet,
backpedal going on there,
but it's true.
If you do live in the woods like that you,
there's a high possibility that you might be fucking crazy or hiding from the
law or hiding from the wall when you see people but out there for a lot,
even if they didn't start out crazy,
you go bush right now.
Tell me this.
Do you take that in consideration when you think about this experience like
you're like,
man,
did I fucked this up in my head?
Did I have no reference point because I was alone for too long out there and did
I just give myself some
sort of a jolt,
like an extra emotional charge to my memory that may have distorted it and as I
repeated it over and over again in my memory,
I might have twisted it a little bit and jumped it up or move to the side to
side or you rock solid that that's exactly what happened.
Absolutely.
Option one,
I haven't got a freaking clue.
I could have been messed up.
Absolutely agree with you.
I question all of those experiences and having him out there.
That was a very honest of you.
That's very honest of you.
I think that was a raven.
I think that was a squirrel.
That's a track I can't account for.
Those branches are just broken because the snow load,
these ones aren't broken because of snow load.
Just like I don't,
I haven't freaking clue.
I can be just mumbling.
But at the end,
that was probably a freaky experience.
But was that it's freaky as being above the tiger.
What was more freaky?
Being above the tire.
Yeah,
I would imagine.
Right.
Because this is real.
This is,
you know,
it's,
as long as it says it's there,
it is confirmed animal.
Yeah.
Confirmed kills people.
I was gonna say earlier at that place,
the sooner bands,
they've killed 300,000 people in the last 200 years.
Tigers were responsible for 300,000 confirmed deaths.
That's insane.
That is a crazy number.
Like you,
you,
you researched it.
I listened to that in a documentary and then like,
that can't be true.
So then I went and I googled all these different sources and that's essentially
the number.
Somewhere around there,
somewhere between two and 300,000 that's fucking insane,
man.
That's insane.
Even if it's like,
okay,
200 years,
even as 200,000 think about how many fucking people that their kid jack by
tigers.
That's a fucking pile of people,
man.
If y'all a pile of 200,000 people,
oh my God,
that's terrifying.
That's a thousand a year.
It's hippos.
That's three a day.
Water Buffalo two,
that's three a day,
right?
1,000 a year.
It's like three a day or close to it in that neighborhood.
Two to three a day.
Every fucking day for 200 years.
Oh my God.
Like fuck the wolf man.
You know.
Fuck big foot tigers.
That's real.
What a crazy animal man.
And we're like working really hard to make sure they stay alive so they can keep
eating those Indians.
Fuck man.
Indians have to be the nicest people ever.
They know the tigers are gonna eat them and they still want to make sure their
populations healthy.
Wow.
It must be the nicest people I've met.
Really Nice people.
They must be ones I know.
Yeah,
I mean it only,
that's the only way that actually fought very hard to make sure that the tigers
are kept very safe and that's why they works up.
That's amazing.
Is that why they worship cows and the cows like walk around the streets so that
they are like bait?
I couldn't figure out that.
That's actually smart.
Mark Hauser ways you to get them people with guns good away from me.
The whole thing is bananas.
The the,
the fact that they starve but they won't eat the cows and then the fact that
they want the,
how did they develop this unusual over there,
Joe.
Not Pot grows in profuse amounts all over the roads.
Everywhere you can get it down the street.
His store,
they weigh it for you.
They mentioned it.
You don't have to go to fucking luck.
I'm talking about you pull up a new driveway and on either side of your
driveway.
It's like a field of hotspots.
Bizarre need to grow it indoors and I can't get rid of it.
I'm trying to hand it out to people.
Quarter last week.
Jesus Christ.
You don't need pot to be growing everywhere and come to India.
Avoid Nick Tigers,
but stay for the weed everywhere.
Man.
This is California.
Nia for weed.
That's ridiculous.
That's a poor plan.
Go for the people.
That makes sense.
I would like to go just to treat.
I would really love to experience like what?
What it's like to talk to a real guru.
I know goof on a lot of those dudes,
those Yogis and those.
What's a real guru?
I don't know man.
I think like all things,
there's got to be someone that's doing it right.
It's probably insanely difficult to be like a real Yogi.
Like a real master who's really like a sod.
Do some dude who just smokes hash all day and meditates and goes into poses with
Assad.
Do an Indian laughs.
Yeah,
well that's what they do,
right?
It was intense.
It was wet and I would like to talk to a one of those real dudes who's really
out there doing it and he's not doing publicity tours,
are trying to sell books.
He doesn't have a podcast.
He's just out there smoking hash and stretching.
So what do you,
what do you think of what that guy has living off?
Nothing.
No food.
No water.
It's bullshit.
100% okay.
This is a bullshit artist.
That guy's nuts.
That's why you know about them.
The reason why you know about him,
he's just telling me I don't do it.
I don't drink.
I just take into [inaudible].
Fuck Outta here.
Shut up.
I went to this guy's house,
when's this guy's office to film?
An episode of the Scifi show.
And as I walked in that this,
the thing that he supposedly could do turned out to be bullshit.
But as we walked in and he has this picture of,
this Indian guy is a man from India and he has white paint all over his face and
he has no shirt on.
He was like this weird dress.
He's wearing these weird clothes.
He's dressed in and a,
I say,
who's that guy goes,
oh,
well he is actually achieved the highest state of enlightenment and he has
existed without water or food for the past 13 years.
I go,
no,
he hasn't.
No,
Why is he fat?
He's,
he's still fat,
he's still fat.
He doesn't eat,
and he just didn't get the fuck Outta here,
man.
And then I was like,
well,
I can't believe I'm at this guy's office.
I'm going to listen to some bullshit thing.
You can't say a guy has lived without food for 13 years.
Put that motherfucker in one of those David Blaine
boxes and let's watch him.
Yeah.
What's,
watch him for a few years.
Come on,
let me see how long it takes for you.
Starve to death.
You fuckhead the chances to say that
the gories you ever read about the Horace?
What does that in India,
these are the,
the high enlightened next level from Sadie sort of thing.
And they,
they live off eating the dead people that are in the guns,
Ganga Ganga River.
Oh my God.
They,
they'll go down and they'll dealt eat.
The body's just Google a gory and Google Aghori a and a,
I think.
And,
and,
and they,
they practice necrophilia.
Oh my God.
Yeah,
they fucked the dead bodies.
He do.
Oh.
And this is part of all the sorts of states of enlightenment there in the eat
excrement they eat,
they'll drink gear in it.
You just live this way.
They or the rule of thumb is accept the unacceptable.
Wow.
It's insane to they're there right now.
Ooze and yeah.
Well it's all about connecting with Shiva and if you do this,
you're denying self and blah,
blah,
blah.
But it's intense.
Hannibal monks of Vera and Nasa,
Nasa Indian tribe.
It's a freaking place to go.
Let's drink from skulls and live among the dead.
Not like fun headlines.
They do it like God there and they did it.
Did you encounter these people?
Uh,
I saw one sort of walking through the street kind of thing.
I mean,
what the fuck man?
They eat the dead.
They,
and that's a natural practice for them.
Yeah.
And what's the thought behind it?
Uh,
that they're taking in the worst of the sins of all and that sort of,
they can connect with Shiva much stronger because of that,
because it's not affecting them.
What are they wearing all over them?
Is that white ash ash from the dead bodies?
All my God.
So they take the ash from the dead buys.
They smear it all over themselves and that went well.
They're finishing off the leg bone.
Oh my God.
And then they just,
they meditate and they do yoga.
Yeah.
What in the fuck?
Jesus Christ.
That guy's got like blood in his beard.
Is that what that is?
Maybe an artifact of the camera.
How shitty Joe when eight people and walking dead.
Don't,
don't lie it.
That made you a little hungry for steak though,
right?
When you're just chewing that big piece of meat,
it's looked good.
No,
it looked like he was eating something that wasn't a person.
Right.
Maybe it personally is good.
Yeah.
Especially with the people supposedly tastes like pig.
Cannibals would call them long pig,
like long pig as a,
an expression for for human meat.
They apparently we taste a lot like pigs,
which is really weird,
man.
It's really,
we're cannibalism freaks people out.
Rightly so.
Like seeing that,
that was a very bizarre video or verbs are a series of images.
Looking at those people knowing that those people have eaten bodies.
Yeah.
There's something about looking at someone that you know,
eats bodies and they don't eat bodies because they're in a plane crash and they
have to do it to survive the at the bodies because that's just what they
do.
They kill no,
no,
absolutely not.
In fact,
they're there.
People come to them to be healed.
What's their breath like?
Must be insanely bad.
Um,
they brush,
floss,
anything.
Well,
if they philosophies,
human hair loss with you ain't got now these people that they get from the river
that there are people that drown or something like that.
You know how they cremate their dead download and then they let them,
they leave them floating along and Oh wait,
what is this sort of thing said to collect these remains?
He used them for spiritual enlightenment wearing costumes.
Oh,
uh,
wearing the corpses,
consuming them or building altars from them.
What they're parading up dead bodies in the street.
Oh my God.
They were the corpses.
Wear them like what?
Tie them to their body.
What advise on a dude's wearing.
One of the corpses.
That's pretty soon.
That was weird,
man.
To seeing them walk down with that body knowing that they have like little
rituals they do with their bodies or what we do is weird too.
Right.
How's embalming?
And he fucking less creepy than that.
Embalmings creepy.
It's super creepy.
Yeah.
I'd rather be burned.
Just are blown up.
That'd be cool to be blown up.
Joey Diaz had a friend and they knew someone who died,
like a young lady and the parents showed up at the,
at the,
uh,
funeral power and the guy came back from doing something with the body and he
was sweaty and he was out of breath and they were thinking that this guy might
have fucked their dead daughter.
Like this is a possibility.
I'm pretty sure Joe,
he told me this story and they saw this guy sweating and heaving and there was
this weird feeling in the air and then they fight.
They found that out a few times.
There's been quite a few times her guys got busted doing that.
Oh,
it happens a lot.
Oh my God.
It must.
It must,
especially with people that are really fucked up in the head and then on top of
being fucked up in the head,
they somehow or another get a job where they have access to a dead bodies.
They get super comfortable around being around dead bodies and they just look at
this warm tit from some chicken.
You got shot in the head five hours ago.
This was fun.
Yeah,
and you get seen from a Tarantino movie.
God Damn,
that's people,
man.
There's a lot of people out there that I like that messed up.
But to see that man,
to see that there's a whole culture based on some how or another that was
bizarre and there is a whole culture based on it.
It's not like there's three people,
there's like lots of them and they have sex with a corpse and they have sex with
the corpses and they consume them.
They were,
and that they like,
they're just trying to break all taboos.
Right.
Is that what they're trying to do except the unacceptable?
What does he do at drinking from the skull?
Oh my God,
Jesus Christ.
What does he drinking?
Uh,
it may be either human urine or feces or carbonate fucking change price son.
Where's your father?
That's so weird,
man.
It's a bizarre cultural,
but it's looking at it.
It's like,
it's so weird.
Like,
look behind him.
You have that,
was that a Buddha or Shiva?
Shiva.
Shiva image behind him.
So you're,
you know,
you're dealing with someone who's practicing.
So you might go,
like,
you might go to be cured of something from this guy and he would like,
they,
they have the girls knew that guy with his head filled with shit in your head
has take aspirin and go to cvs and take some aspirin.
You need more tigers.
Definitely.
I agree.
Yeah.
Tigers to take those assholes out.
How many of those people get killed a year by tigers?
Probably none.
Well,
we need to do is get big foot in a tiger together in the octagon and sue,
who's the king and the God damn forest.
My money's on tiger.
Yeah.
I take tiger over big foot all day.
When was the last time?
Big Foot jump?
14 feet through the air to bitch slap somebody.
Yeah,
so that tire can do.
How many Sasquatch do you actually estimate are up there?
I don't estimate anything like that.
Do you think there's any,
do I think there's any,
any?
I think that the possibility of something exists.
What the fuck it is?
I don't know.
Okay.
If you had to guess though,
if you had to,
if I gave you,
if we said,
listen,
this is the lottery right now.
This is the world lottery.
You got two choices.
One side is,
yes,
this is a real animal.
It exists.
One side has no,
you got to push all your chips on one side.
Which way are you going to go?
I'd go,
yes,
I'm going all down all day.
I'll tell you,
you know why?
Because even though they did find the Hobbit Moans,
they did find this fanged vampire a deer.
It just seems like all those things are like way more possible than bigfoot.
For whatever reason,
big foot feels,
and I know this isn't,
this isn't logical.
This isn't scientific.
It feels like bullshit.
There's so much bullshit.
It's thoughts.
Feelings aren't facts and,
and that's all.
Your mom's a little defensive because on both sides,
both sides got nothing.
You're right.
Well that's not totally true because the absence of evidence doesn't necessarily
mean there's evidence.
But the fact that there's like these zero evidence lead,
this not real anecdotal references don't count.
It doesn't count because people were full of shit.
And this,
this is the most hilarious one.
The Patterson Footage Jersey.
That looks real.
The fuck out of here.
That's so dumb.
The fact that scientists actually examine that thing for decades.
Well,
I believe the gate perhaps could be a very unusually shaped person,
but my money,
so I was not a dude with a monkey suit on with football pads on no
unknown monkey and none monkey.
I don't know.
It could be real.
I wouldn't tell you what I'd be most happy,
most happy if it was real.
I don't know why,
but if they did find big foot who probably next to my daughter's birth probably
be the happiest day of my life.
I'll tell you I my two lesbian bigfoot cause it cause it.
You know what?
Because it means it's still freaking magic in the world.
That's why if that's,
if it's real,
it has a lot of magic going on.
There's some cool shit going on up there.
Okay.
Narnia.
I ain't going to say and match
episode 78 of come to me.
Big Foot magics to what I meant was tool is cool.
Shit still going.
Yeah.
Well No,
look,
there's a lot of cool shit that's alive.
That's one of my main points about all this as you're right.
Why do we need something unknown to get so excited about biology when it's
things like that shoe build,
that thing is fucking bizarrely evil looking real giant prehistoric bird.
It does.
Big Foot is closer to us than we.
That's what,
than we think.
Right?
And he's been looking at that saying,
look at that mosque Corker.
Jesus Christ had things evil.
If you go for cool factor,
that thing is so crazy.
If you've like looked at,
if I,
if you didn't know that was a real animal.
And he said,
look at this evil thing and this new hobbit movie,
it's uh,
the,
one of the things that attacks the hobbit or five foot tall birds that don't
fly.
And the Predator and they have a giant bill that's like the size of that's like,
I mean,
what does that thing like two feet long,
they're bills.
It looks fuck out.
It looks exactly like the dark crystal creature.
Remember that creature from the dark crystal Similac go.
You're like that.
Well,
you know,
that's one of the things that they know existed in North America.
This terror bird that put that to shame.
That's like a five foot tall version of this terrible bird was even bigger with
an even bigger beak and they didn't even find out about that thing until,
I want to say like 20 or 30 years ago they started discovering the fossils.
I don't,
I might be wrong,
but I don't think it was that long ago.
But yeah,
he does research,
please.
That's why I said what did the size of that fucking thing?
I the picture,
that thing next to a person named Matt,
it's cool as shit,
right?
I like how it's next to a soldier
that fucking hunt them.
Plastic army men of that God damn thing.
What the fuck that was that big?
How tall is that dude?
Is that Bobby Lee?
How tall is that?
Dixie,
an army soldier from a toy story.
Six foot tall.
So it says,
it doesn't say,
well,
I represent the average person,
which I believe the average male in America is like five 10.
So think about
how God look up big.
It is next to a faux wagon.
What thought?
Fuck man.
Sure.
Imagine you step out of your back porch and you see something bigger than a
fucking moose and it's just a giant bird.
It's predatory.
And he owns a Volkswagen beetle.
What do they eat?
What the fuck did they eat?
Anything they want.
What do they eat?
I mean,
that must be a fucking hungry bitch.
The size of the thing to keep that much mass.
Oh my God.
He says 180 kilograms,
which is what does that 400 pounds?
300 something pounds.
400 kilograms is 2.2 pounds per kilogram.
So 400 kilograms is more than 800 pounds.
Say Eight eight,
right?
8,000 pounds.
1000 pounds.
Yeah,
for 400 kilogram somewhere around in the neighborhood.
Right.
What the fuck?
A thousand pound bird that just runs around biting people.
And then there's other thing is smaller,
but it looks bigger.
Why is it look bigger?
But why is it,
why do they,
uh,
it's taller.
It's taller,
taller and thinner,
but it doesn't have as much mass.
Oh,
okay.
Well I'm scared of the one I left now.
That fucking ruthless bitch.
Why is he so much heavier?
It's more than twice as heavy.
And the other one's taller.
And the one on the right,
if you looked at those,
you would say,
which one's heavier?
Probably the one on the right,
right.
I'm getting more scared of the one on the right,
just because of its beak that keeps him pretty damaging
or not.
Uh,
I think from Jurassic Park,
that one looks so predatory that the reason why it's so thin is because it eats
so much that it burns calories while it's eating.
It's killing you and burning your count is to constantly be in a state of
murder,
just to fuel that fucking face.
You then thing grown off of its head.
Imagine
you've got a giant hatchet,
big bolt cutters that murders like that dude's yeah.
Hell and you're nine feet tall in your way.
Whatever it is.
300 pounds,
300 plus pounds.
Three 60 what does it,
what's one 80 what's one 80 kilograms?
Well I thought fuck 500 fucking pounds.
Bird biting.
You
look in his eyes.
No mercy missions just dead like you're looking into a mirror just dead as it's
eating your asshole
alerts.
It's babies that have found one.
Why is it Amy's coming a lot all over cause they do animal start asshole
firsthand.
You know that as much as I do right now.
So they start with your asshole.
It's one of the things the coyotes do that so horrific.
When you find deer there's still half alive there.
Their bottom end is eaten away.
They eat their asshole and their legs and oftentimes they're still alive.
They think there might be something like advantages to killing animals at les
and keeping them alive because it preserves the meat for a little bit than if
they just went right to the neck.
Cause like this guy that I was at w up in BC with,
it was a moose hunter.
So they came across this moose that had been alive for a days and these wolves
were eating it for days.
It was still alive and they would just eat its legs.
There was just tearing at it's asshole and they were eating its back legs and
the Moose couldn't get up.
He couldn't get away.
They were keeping it there.
But like half of his back end was gone and he was still alive.
Fuck nature.
Few scary,
scary,
scary bitch nature and there you are sleeping in trees
but in the middle of it and there was a deer that that happened to an India when
we were there,
the local dogs had taken it.
All they did was they broke its both its hind legs and then they,
then they backed off and they let it sit there.
Oh it's a two broken back legs.
And we just looked at us like,
oh man.
Oh Man.
And then he started eating and you know the dogs are going to either rip it
apart that night or the Tigers were going to come down and take it or the
leopards.
Woo.
So yeah,
still out there doing,
I'm still out there sleeping in those places.
You why you still doing this?
Because you don't have to still do this.
You could do anything.
You actually in a better mood doing it now than it was in a couple of years ago.
I'm,
I'm kind of enjoying and I came back on this season like a swan song.
Like let's,
let's have some fun.
Let's enjoy that.
So I'm going to cool places.
Mongolia,
what are you going to do on my bitcoin?
Survivorman Tanga India,
some beautiful,
amazing places.
So
have you seen that?
A new tribe that they found in Mongolia that rides on Caribou.
They have like tame Caribou and they ride them around.
It's crazy.
They,
they use animals to hunt.
They've trained wolves and they've trained a eagles to hunt for them.
You know,
they've known that they've been able to do that for a while.
Like train Golden Eagles to like take out smaller animals they take out dear.
But this tribe,
they have domesticated Caribou,
they've domesticated reindeer and they're on on for awhile.
It's wild man.
They ride them around like their horses.
It's like,
and that's in Mongolia.
Yup.
Crazy.
That's a crazy part of the
world,
man.
Yup.
That's why I'm really enjoying this season.
I'm going to places I haven't been before the drought.
Is it like there's a guy look at that that's or a woman have believe that she's
riding a Caribou like gets up fucking horse.
Is it welcome?
Like,
like you're doing one thing that it's like,
man,
am I wasting my time?
Like what is this?
Like what?
I can need to see something.
But the other hand,
if you did find something,
if you were up there and you got great footage of this fucking big monkey
bounding between two or three trees,
just looking at you and saying,
fuck,
he got me.
Holy Shit.
If we were like,
we weren't crazy,
these 200 different native American names for this animal,
it wasn't crazy.
People want to know that.
That thing's real.
That isn't real.
Like I fuck around.
And I joke around about it not being real,
but the reality is,
I don't fucking know.
We really don't know.
There's,
there's too many people that have said that there's something up there.
It doesn't mean that there's something up there.
It means the woods are scary.
The dance,
it gets dark out.
People make shit up.
People know that other people made shit up to hear the stories.
I think one of their real,
I think I might have saw it too,
and then it builds up in your mind.
That's possible too.
But it's all impossible.
There's a giant,
undiscovered primate.
If anybody catches it,
I hope it's,
you know,
that's,
not dean Cain bringing enhancer bastard that's mixed.
Deserve it.
Let's make lock mix.
Loch ness with big foot.
What if big foot lived under water and that's where he hid out.
And then like,
he like the water up there.
That's a stupid idea.
Shot down in flames.
That doesn't work.
It's not like he lives near a lake.
If they didn't,
you know what they believe on that show.
Um,
river monsters.
River monsters show.
They think they figured out what the lake Champlain monsters.
They think it's a sturgeon.
Enormous sturgeon.
Cause apparently there are sturgeons there and they've caught sturgeon.
Sturgeon get e normous enormous.
Have you ever seen a sturgeon?
Oh my God.
I saw one in real life the other day.
I saw one in Mexico that someone had caught.
Fuck Dude,
that's a big goddamn fish.
Then when I saw it was small,
but they had them on the show that that Jeremy,
whatever his name is,
one of the gentlemen who runs river monsters that goes a fishing.
That guy's legit,
right?
Yeah.
He doesn't seem to have any fucker on his shows.
He was in Lake Champlain and they had a photo of this thing from overhead and it
looked exactly like a giant sturgeon.
You're talking like a 16 foot long sturgeon.
Like they really get that big.
They do still sit and they look like a dinosaur.
Prehistoric animal.
That's a sturgeon.
Okay.
Yes.
That's a pretty big one.
See,
look at that.
That's a lake Champlain sturgeon.
So someone caught that in lake Champlain.
Hmm.
I believe that's what that's saying.
Is that what that's saying?
Is that what I'm saying?
Okay,
so these are absolutely real sturgeon.
They've caught in Lake Champlain and there's one that big and that's probably
like five feet long,
something like that.
That one,
maybe the other one was a little bit bigger,
but they believe that there's some enormous ones in there.
And I think that that river monsters guy,
look at that one.
That guy's got and his arm.
Look at that one right there.
That's not a surgeon.
That's a,
that's a pike.
The one next to it.
The one right next to it.
If you go down,
look at that.
Doesn't pay fucking fish,
man.
That's a big fish.
That's like a person.
It's a person fish.
But the uh,
the,
the really big ones,
if you take a photo of giant sturgeon or a Google giant sturgeon and you'll get
an image of what they'd look like at their very biggest 16 feet long.
Yeah,
there were an enormous prehistoric fish.
The only,
like the Gar is the only one that's creepier.
The alligator Gar.
Creepy,
aren't they?
They have like armor,
their bodies covered in our,
we look at that,
look at the fucking size of that thing.
Holy Shit.
That's a painting.
Let's say a painting to me is your ticket for falling asleep on these chairs.
Look real dicks asleep.
Fucking dicks checked out.
Dude.
It's tired of what you've been doing to it.
It's like we're done.
We're going numb.
Next thing that we're going to tie ourselves and not hang herself while you're
sleeping.
It seems that the biggest one that could find,
oh my God.
Oh my God.
Look at that thing.
It's huge.
Holy Fuck.
What does that 10 feet long?
That's probably 10 feet long,
right?
Last,
if you had to guess.
Nine nine look at he's conservative.
Love them.
Yeah.
Fucking Christ.
At 70 years old,
he catches a huge 350 pounds sturgeon in British Columbia.
That's where he was.
God,
look at that God damn thing so heavy.
It towed his boats for half an hour.
Oh my God.
Before the pensioner was able to pull,
Hey Lisa Guy,
leave him alone.
Just cause he's old.
You've got to pull out the fact that he's on his pension.
Fuck off.
Six tried to diminish the man's achievement.
He see Starbuck would just say Starbucks.
That's his last name is as [inaudible] at Starbucks.
Mr Starbuck.
Look at the size of that day.
So those are the alligator gars pull up a giant alligator gar.
I think these are even more creepy because sturgeons I don't think they eat much
meat.
They eat like little fish and whatever.
They suck off the bottom right.
Isn't that the deal with them at a bottom?
Theaters bottom feeders,
but um,
alligator guards,
they look way more predatory.
That picture of the mouth down there.
Fuck.
There's one above that,
Jamie.
Or where was it?
Go back to the,
those other images.
There was one.
Now there's a better one.
That guy has its mouth wide open where you can get a good look at that one right
there.
Right there.
Yeah,
it's actually alligator.
Oh,
what the fuck man?
Look at that thing.
Oh my God,
that's a Florida Gar.
How is that a real animal?
That thing looks so crazy.
That's pretty historic.
Let me see.
The alligator right next to it.
The one that we thought was it.
See,
you're right in the images down there on the right.
Lower right hand side related images.
Yeah,
right there.
Bam.
That is a Gar.
That's what I was thinking it was.
Let me just go to that image.
Oh my God.
Look at the size of that thing.
Most people don't even know what this is.
No.
Most people have no idea what a Gar is.
If you,
bro,
that's a sturgeon.
If you brought that up to them,
they'd be like,
what?
Go back to that one where they see the guys,
the jaw,
where we thought it was an alligator.
The middle of the bar.
Yeah.
Look at that.
Go to the full image of that.
Let's end with this fucking,
the world is filled with mixture.
Ladies and gentlemen,
don't be so quick to say that Sasquatch isn't real when that's fucking thing.
Swimming around.
Have you seen the penis snake yet?
What does the piece sound?
This snake that it's called.
There are Roth though.
Chone we need Ya.
But if you just type in penis snake,
it's a snake from Brazil I believe.
Yes.
It looks like a penis.
Yeah,
it looks like a big heart or long pianists.
How about those fucking things in the where those guys
pee in the water.
They have to cut their hand over their dick because there's fish that will fly
right up your urethra.
Catfish.
Yeah.
This one right here.
That's a big black one too.
Yeah,
that's a nice one.
That's a nice cut.
Yeah,
it's a cut.
It's a nice card.
So it's got the helmet cover on this ready to bust out.
It's got a very long for skin.
Couldn't be right.
Like it's all tied up in a knot in the,
in the top.
I look at that.
It's wrinkles.
I mean that looks like a Dick Right there.
That's my deck.
Looks like if you need to go to a doctor immediately,
your Dixie hydrated.
It's probably dead.
I mean like what?
Sick Dick.
When I have a sick tick,
tick,
tick.
Whenever,
I don't know,
four months,
I allow good sick Dick.
Hmm.
Let me send one of these photos to a girl and see if she thinks it's a dick.
Like a blue kind of shakes your dating.
I had a bet.
Tell him it was fucking a dicon.
Narnia.
Just make it black and white.
It's a Dick on the moon.
Look,
we've got a picture from the rover.
That's a more door dick.
Come on son.
This did you see that Scientology documentary and these people out there that'll
believe anything.
You see that going so that,
yeah,
part of the book.
I didn't see the documentary yet,
but I heard it's amazing.
Okay.
Is there any correlation between the belief and Xenu and the belief in
Sasquatch?
It's gotta be very similar.
There is a little bit of this need for this fucking thing to be real.
That clouds the judgment and I applaud the fact that you went into this as
objectively as a unique individual as you could.
It's no,
you know,
no one is completely objective.
I think we all strive to be,
especially if you're really trying to give a good audit of your life and trying
to figure out how you're running things.
How objective am I being about this Goddamn big foot thing?
You know,
it's tricky.
Use a lot invested in it.
You know,
you're out there.
It would suck if it wasn't real.
And you've been out there what,
how many times now?
Not to me at all.
But at this point,
this is a eight h nine shows.
I still got the same way.
It's like bring it,
bring it down.
Does that guy that you're with,
you said you had issues with him?
Uh,
and while there's a whole bunch of different people that I go out there with
[inaudible] I don't have any issues with Todd.
Everybody else does.
I don't know everybody else.
Yeah.
So is it possible that what we're looking at right there actually was a big
foot.
Okay.
I Dunno,
I haven't got a clue.
If you had to put all your money,
so if you have the at all you can
no matter what.
And knowing him and knowing that stuff,
I still sit with 50 50 on,
it was just like well could be or couldn't be
l o l
yeah.
Ah,
cause you're 99.9 hundred and 100 here.
100% that's affecting was just sitting there while everybody else that even
claims to have seen one says they fucking bolt because the blink again.
I want to see the blame.
That's how a person winks.
Watch.
Oh my God.
And what's smash cut from there to there.
What happened there will blink.
Ooh,
Ooh.
They should be playing.
Well that's on.
Nope.
Have you tried to get that guy to take a polygraph test though?
Nah,
that's not a bad idea.
Well what the fuck?
What am I going to figure this whole thing out for it?
I need to be a secret show.
I called Jim and it wouldn't allow me on the show.
They're busy.
Shit.
We'll go one episode with me.
I be like,
this guy's full of shit less.
We're out in the woods.
He that's bullshit.
That's what we should do is come on son,
take this polygraph test.
You'd be the skeptic.
I'll be the open guy.
Oh Tom.
Okay.
And you could just do that every show.
How I'm probably both be the skeptic.
Let's be done with this.
That's true,
but I still stay at the staff to say,
this is,
I watched the show.
First of all,
I think that the area where you're at is so remote.
It's incredible.
I mean it's an incredible piece of wilderness and one of the things that when we
went big foot hunting for that Scifi show,
this guy told us he was a really cool guy.
He goes,
look,
even if there is no big foot,
we're still camping.
We're still out here camping.
We're having a good time.
When I enjoy it,
it's best part and he really did feel that way.
We got was not bullshitting so that area,
like it's,
there's nothing lost and exploring that area is it is on the show.
I said,
you know what?
Let's look at it this way.
Let's say they don't exist at all.
Worst case scenario,
I get an awesome night and my tent on the edge of a lake and it's beautiful and
you are experiencing this intense wild nature,
which makes you feel like real,
really connected to life.
That's the thing about when you're in those woods and you're in those remote
areas,
you must feel intensely connected to life.
Yeah.
Did in a weird way that you don't get connected,
reconnected?
Is that the way to describe it?
I would think reconnected.
Yeah.
In a way you're never going to get in a city.
That's right.
It's a different experience.
Like you,
you feel different.
You feel different.
When you were,
you're like so attached to the nature that's around you.
You,
you,
you were immersed in it.
You're a part of it.
When you're,
when you're in the woods,
the woods doesn't give a fuck about your four o one k plan and doesn't give a
fuck if you have your insurance card and your glove compartment.
It doesn't give a fuck if you're left tire starting to run low.
It doesn't give a fuck.
Nature doesn't give a fuck about any of the variables that you present.
It's like this is what we have to offer.
It's a wild shootout.
It's a wild shootout between predators and prey and there's limited food supply
and there's a bunch of animals darting around left and right and shitting in the
woods.
Good luck.
That's,
that's what you feel when you're out there.
You feel this like,
wow,
maybe the stock market really isn't like the epicenter of the universe.
Maybe it doesn't really matter in the greater scheme of the universe whether or
not I owe money on my student loans,
maybe it doesn't really matter if I'm in credit card debt and my wife is banging
her trainer,
maybe it doesn't matter.
That's why I squint.
Go out to the Bush when you were at.
Yeah.
When you're out there,
it puts the whole ball of wax a,
you might be completely wrapped up in your own weird thing to the point where
you don't recognize the fact that you're a part of nature.
You're not.
You just removed because you have walls,
you have electricity and you have a hat on,
but you're a part of nature,
an unavoidable part of it.
You're in there,
you're in it.
It's even if big foot is bullshit,
there's still something that nature is so wild that the possibility of big foot
isn't outside of the realm of what you would consider to have a,
a potential reality to it.
It's not outside of it.
It's in the realm.
Bingo.
Survivorman thank fun tune in.
If you,
if you do find something,
would you please bring it to us immediately?
Can we get a scoop?
Okay.
You got this good for real thrill.
Snapchat,
meaningful
exchange.
Our snapchats and yeah,
it'll be like what you sent me today?
You fuck he sends you this fucking thing.
Oh,
it's horrible
ball.
This is the type of person he is.
He sends me this,
uh,
this text message that Isis as a closed down the four oh five.
Let's see if it affects any of the areas where you live.
Click this link.
Oh
yeah.
And here's the click the link and
I ain't go Jamie.
Seriously.
Yeah.
It was in the airport in Mexico and I was like,
you mother fucker.
I paid Verizon Rumi data for the buck deck.
I don't think it was that much.
You know,
throw you in jail for that.
Right.
Um,
I'm actually in Mexico.
They're nice people.
They're not so uptight.
They're there.
That's a fucking great part of the world.
If it wasn't for all the drug war shit and all the bullshit like Mexican people,
the nicest fucking people.
They're so nice.
And if I had like one food to choose from to the day I die,
it would be a tough call between Italian food and Mexican food.
Really?
Yes.
What do you think?
Italian?
102% a year.
A pasta eater,
right?
No,
no,
no.
I rarely eat pasta,
but I also know that,
uh,
Mexicans food,
it's just like three minutes,
three ingredients,
you know,
it's just everything's the same.
It's been,
or
no,
no.
You got to a t,
you know,
you get a real Mexican joint like you have,
like they do the best skirt steak in the world,
like the,
the best like skirt steak,
the Mexican restaurants where they marinate it and they,
God damn,
man,
there's a lot of Mexican dishes that,
where they do it correctly.
Like we had some fish in Mexico,
like fresh caught snapper,
like oh ho Ho.
They have the best.
They invented [inaudible].
They invented cooking things in lime juice.
You have like really good.
So BJ from fresh fish.
Oh,
it's unbelievably delicious.
With a little bit of lime and some Cilantro in there.
A little bit of onions and tomatoes.
Is Pizza part of this?
These kids in pizzas doughy.
The problem with me and invented by the Jenny's anyway,
whatever it is,
bro,
we took it.
We made a little bit better.
You know what I'm saying?
Okay,
so the nodal we took good with Bulla box assaults on that.
I don't know my,
I'm not an efficient Natto in the fucking history of gluten,
but I do know that when I eat too much of it,
it fucks me up.
It's just a convert.
Your body converts it to sugar.
I call that a year eating a bowl of sugar.
When you eat a bowl of pasta,
you're eating a bowl of white flour,
you're eating a bowl of sugar.
I mean,
that's really what your body thinks it is.
You get this crazy insulin fucking thing happening,
your body's like,
what is all this is why you don't get that.
If you just eat like vegetables and meats and even beans don't give you that
spike the same way that the Po that those pasta dishes and heavy heavy bred
dishes,
which is not good for you man.
They're just not,
they tastes fucking amazing.
You know,
like a good lasagna.
Oh Christ.
That belly stretching feeling when you know you've eaten something virtually in
indigestible,
but it's awesome tour of Italy.
Sure.
That's great.
I'm sure I,
you know,
I would love to know what pasta was light before they started monkeying around
with wheat because they,
they think that like somewhere around the early 19 hundreds they started like
doing something to wheat to make it more durable,
to make a greater yields and to make it being able to be a little bit more hardy
and they just changed the way we grows.
They changed the actual consistency of the plant and from then on it became like
harder and harder for people that digested.
Apparently.
That's the idea.
And then the other idea is that these processed flours,
it's just your advisor's not,
that's not how it's supposed to be eaten by.
Doesn't know what to do with that.
It's like,
what the fuck is this?
Like eat a bowl of sugar.
Like if you had some sugar and you put that doesn't exist in nature and nature,
sugar comes attached to fiber to come at.
It comes attached to vitamins.
It's like a reward for eating fruit.
Like you get a,
you eat oranges,
it tastes delicious.
You getting that sugar,
but you're also getting vitamin C,
you're getting all that fiber.
It's a,
it's like a trick to get you to eat something delicious so that you will shit
out the seeds and fertilize those seats.
Like nature's got a whole system set up.
It doesn't exist.
What I'll bowl of sugar,
you pour a bowl of sugar on your fucking frosted flakes.
Like that's something that doesn't exist in nature.
Tell me you didn't do that.
Did you ever have frosted flakes and you poured sugar on top of them?
Like double frost,
them bitches.
Narita.
That sounds great though.
I've done licious it's delicious.
You know,
darkness and Double Frost and frosted flakes fucking sucked his sugar.
It was shuck spoonfuls of it.
And then you drink the milk.
[inaudible] coconut water.
Nope.
It's better.
Frosted flake milk might be the best thing.
Our
Champagne.
How much are you paying for that Cabernet Sauvignon?
You need frosted flakes.
Goddamn frosted flakes.
Milk put that shit.
Great.
If you were in the mood for frosted flakes milk at the end of a bowl of frosted
flakes that you double sugared and someone already you a glass of Cabernet
Blake,
get that sloppy,
nasty,
bitter shit out of my face about to feast on some flakes.
Milk,
raisin bran with sugar.
What do you think before eats?
It's gotta be a lot.
He's pretty big.
If you had to guess off elk,
elk,
probably some mushrooms.
What did they say?
They say elk.
Mushrooms,
berries,
roots,
tubers,
shoots,
grasses,
deer.
But it was elk.
Wouldn't you find like a carcass like sampling?
We found uh,
a moose carcass.
I was up in BC that had been killed by wolves.
All these,
these,
these researchers say they do find them.
Really these researchers are the ones that where I got to go on.
It's just people who were into this subject matter.
Right.
So did they take photos of these carcasses?
They have photos to put them on.
Now they're taking photos and they're measuring them.
And that was doing everything scientifically now.
But if you had a carcass,
right,
you'd probably be able to get some DNA off that if something was Predator preys.
And how old of this,
but you know,
you already said yourself,
the DNA thing is pretty unstable,
right?
Out of all those sources of all the different people that are quote unquote
researchers,
what do you think is the most credible organization?
Les Stroud.
They put staff and crew survivorman big foot.
I,
yeah.
Credible.
Yeah.
Four Chan,
four Chan,
I think I read it.
Whoever's got nothing to whoever doesn't have a stake in it.
Yeah.
Right.
But doesn't everybody have a stake in it?
If they really can start?
Once you spend a night in the woods,
you have a stake in it more than the guy who watches it on TV and goes big
church.
That's it.
You have more of a mistake.
That's an emotional state.
I'm talking about financials and will you have a financial stake too?
Because it's not free to go live in the woods.
If you do,
you ain't got to eat food that you have to buy.
You have to make sure that you're not working back in the city and earning
money.
So it'll cost you money in that regard.
You have to have gear which costs money.
You're talking about.
You have to have camping gear.
Okay,
why am I talking about?
What do you mean?
What the fuck that got to do?
Well,
so there's a steak.
You,
you spent,
you spent your time,
which is money,
time equals money to most people and you put that eats a stake in that you've
invested in me.
I mean,
if you're outside of the profit,
if you're out for profit,
okay.
Those guys,
they're suspect,
right?
They gotta be suspect.
Of course they have to be.
Cause if you're a normal human being,
you're going to have a bias.
If that's like how you feed yourself,
like the finding big foot folks.
Like if you really got those dudes high on pot and told them to tell the real
truth about every episode,
like that's a good idea.
What when you were hooting,
you knew that Bobo was hooting back,
right?
Right.
But when the camera was on and you have the night vision on like,
man,
I heard it too.
I heard it.
I heard it for sure.
Wow.
What a night.
We definitely got a call back.
Something called us back and knocked wood.
Who invented what?
Knocking?
Who's that fuck.
I wish I knew somebody just decided that they knocked back and knocked,
came up with a base of wood.
Does anybody,
does,
does anybody to challenge that?
Is there two schools of thought when it comes to wood knockin?
Nah,
it just is what it is.
Either do it or you don't.
Some do,
some don't.
But do you think that Sasquatch is wack sticks against trees?
I don't know.
All I know is they're talking about,
they hear the sounds of like sticks being laggy and street,
so that's why they do it.
Yeah.
One of the guys,
when we were in,
um,
north Pacific northwest,
he was very skeptical about the wood knocking.
So like,
I'm not buying it.
There's like different camps guys.
Like,
well,
that's what I said.
Yeah.
It's at scale of believability and they're all in fighting with,
because everybody wants to be able to say,
I'm the one who figured it out.
I got the film footage.
Like,
is there a Michael Jordan of bigfoot researchers?
Is there one dude that everybody bows down to?
The one at the Hicks and Gracie of bigfoot researchers and he's gotta be,
I don't know.
Are you a knock or,
yeah.
Are you a knocker a hooper?
Oop.
Oop,
oop,
oop.
What do you think about that Samurai chatter you ever heard that you never heard
Samarai chatter.
The Samurai chatter was a guy,
I want to say it was like from the 1970s who a recorded some of vocalizations
that sounded like woo woo.
And he claimed that these were big foot.
He never looked into this.
I haven't heard that one.
Yeah,
we had a sound expert,
uh,
um,
analyze these for that Scifi show.
To me it sounds like total horse shit and he's like a human voice.
Can't make that noise.
I'm like,
yes,
I can hear.
I'll do it.
Like I just did it.
Like don't say a person can't make that.
This is a recording recordings,
especially from like 1970s equipment.
When you're in the woods,
like field equipment,
like you're not getting an absolute exact representation of the sound that
you're recording.
You're getting some sort of whatever the,
the gear is capable of picking up like a really good microphone.
Like these microphones,
these uh,
shores.
Right.
What do these things,
it makes these,
yeah,
these are like a really good microphone.
This is about as close to a Rep.
Like when you hear yourself in a podcast,
you go,
that's definitely made.
That sounds exactly like me,
but this is a recording of you.
Like it's not you,
it's taking you and it's recording the best possible version of your voice.
It can.
It's not you talking again.
So when you hear it,
you're hearing the machine that is picked up some sound that you made and it's
put this down as best it could in 1978 or whatever the fuck it is.
But it's not going to be exact.
It's just not.
So when anybody says a human being can't even make that sound.
Well you're right.
It has to be a tape recorder.
That's what makes that sound and has to record it from a human being.
But once you go through that,
like you're in some gray area,
like who knows?
It could sound like if you,
do you find it?
Did you find it?
Samurai chatter find this Samurai chatter.
Big Foot sounds you're going to hell.
So this sound expert with like,
what's that like part sale is at best buy or no,
he is a ear bud efficient auto.
Oh,
so he has a pair of headphones.
Well he has the beats studio pro,
the Blue K,
he gets the Bluetooth ones.
Where the guy,
I'm the man.
That guy.
He's the,
he's got the kind,
that awkward really hook around the back of the ear when the earbuds?
No,
he was a real sound expert.
He was a,
and he also was like,
uh,
he was in the navy like he deciphered languages in the navy way off in the
remotest parts of the Sierras.
Northern California.
First of all,
I don't trust this British fuck.
Reminds me of Johnny Appleseed.
Apple see mother fucker out.
What the hell it was and I'm so they took up the tape recorder one time and this
is what the recorded,
it's very bizarre indeed.
How many rubber bands you think that kind of has around his balls was making
that noise?
Sounds like an open Mike comp.
We decided to record the sounds on a CD and a cassette and make them available.
See this is a part of the problem we're dealing with from the big for community,
right?
Yeah.
That's my shit.
That kind of shit.
Yup,
exactly.
And when you hear stuff like that,
like what do you think that is?
I haven't got a clue like you say.
I mean that could have been easily recorded by anybody.
What do you think it was Brian?
Totally.
Somebody just doing those noises.
I of course,
they just sounded like an idiot doing it.
Like you could picture that person what they're doing,
making those noises like like an idiot.
I'm offended by his skepticism.
Well,
if it wasn't what it was,
the cubic foot.
Well,
listen,
I wasn't a human then.
What was why we were filming the show and I went over this.
These are some things are considered and one time when were at the ice house,
we got so high that I believe the Patterson footage was real for a few seconds.
I was like,
what if I'm an asshole and what of this whole time that is a real big foot and I
just been mocking it.
I was so high and then I came down.
I was like,
bitch,
that's a guy and might be simply the fucking stupid thing.
It's so odd.
It's if it looks like someone in a monkey suit,
most likely it's someone in a monkey suit.
When you look at a Giraffe,
you never go,
oh,
that looks like a person in a fucking giraffe outfit.
No,
they look like giraffes.
Like they have a very giraffe like way of walking.
That stupid fucking thing walks like a person.
But I might be wrong.
What do you think about that when you think about the Patterson?
I haven't explored it enough.
I Dunno.
I think the coolest,
I think we call,
if you were wrong,
how could it be possible?
You,
you don't really haven't like looked into this even looked into all the,
I sat with the guy who was there.
Which guy?
Yeah.
Sorry.
Okay.
I just didn't smell bullshit on him when he was talking.
It sounded like he was just talking right from his heart.
Like this is what I saw.
Any of our aculeate gambling or being a part of it though.
Right.
They accused Roger Patterson,
the guy who filmed it,
who went to jail for writing a bad check to pay for the very camera.
He used to film big foot.
No one con man.
Right.
And then there was the,
was there though.
And then there was the other guy who said he was in the suit was his name Pablo.
But he was also proven to be bullshitting.
No Way.
Shooters are bullshitting.
Yeah.
That's the problem.
Herana Miss [inaudible].
Mm.
Yeah.
I remembered,
um,
who was a big guy who walked a lot like big foot.
Like this is video footage.
A montage of Bob Hieronymus next to the Patterson footage and he walks just like
it.
Nailed it.
You ever seen that?
No.
Yeah.
He's a big gangly looking cowboy and motherfucker on those dudes.
There's those giant belt buckles and it looks normal on him.
You know a certain dudes,
you see him with a giant like Rodeo belt buckle.
You go there.
Okay.
That's a,
what do you mean?
Where you can pull it off here?
Look at this.
Look at this guy.
Hilarious,
right?
I mean,
c'mon,
that's him.
Tell us about her on a mess.
I mean,
that is Bob Herana Miss.
And that is the big foot thing behind him.
I mean,
Jesus Christ.
Yeah,
it's him.
I mean,
fucking get outta here.
That's that dude.
Hilarious.
Yeah,
he's just getting somebody seen that before.
That's fucking hilarious.
Yeah,
it just get some gorilla arms that are like extra long at the end.
You know you got some fake hand,
had some fake fur thing on
or it's a female Sasquatch.
What'd you think?
Did that titties?
Okay.
If you had to push all your chips,
you got all your money here.
Who are we going to go here less?
What do we do?
I don't know.
We're going all in on,
yes,
it's big foot are all in on Bob Herana.
Miss is telling the truth all in on.
I don't gamble.
Wow.
That's why I'm going out there.
You don't gamble at all?
I can't get more shit.
Come on side.
A little bit of roulette.
A bet on fights would have.
George said that I was fighting.
I did strong Canadian anyway.
You Bet.
So this is like a educated guess as well.
Oh,
okay.
How about this?
Forget it all that.
Okay,
let's make it 50 bucks.
Nothing crazy.
Just bragging rights and 50 bucks.
I'm going with it.
That there's something there.
That thing,
that video.
Oh,
you're talking with a video.
That's the video.
That video.
Oh Shit.
I can't,
I can't gamble on that cause I don't,
I just don't know.
I'm closing my eyes and pushing the whole bag of chips towards bullshit.
Yeah,
I know.
Yeah.
All the money in the role of bullshit.
Wow.
That's a strong word.
He didn't even spell word but world wrong and I don't like girl and he doesn't
like gamble.
It assets.
No condom.
I'm not trying to pitch both covered.
Look,
we're not trying to
name it seems like we're ganging up on you.
Okay.
That's all I take me into your bets.
Listen,
you know I love it.
I'll take you to be successful with your bets.
If all these assholes has got to find this fucking,
this pretends he has big foot and it's cooler.
That shithead Dyer,
all these guys,
the guy who says he shot big foot.
Oh,
he's fucking guys.
Their stories are all very fantastical.
Yeah.
That's why I just look them all straight and vase and go show me what you got.
Oh,
you think it's just scary on the mountain over there.
Okay,
we'll,
I'll stay up there tonight and see what happens.
If one fucking dude had it though.
I imagine one day it takes one footage.
It takes once all the texts.
One Dude,
God damn son.
That would be the coolest shit ever.
Well,
why?
That's what I want to know.
Why would that be cool with than a tiger?
Why would that be cool with than a killer whale?
Why would that be cooler than a shoe?
Because if it's there,
we think it's a missing link.
That's why there's no missing link.
It doesn't really work that way.
That's like some archaic thinking.
Very nonscientific and there's no archaic thinking going on in North America
today.
No,
just not
the religious freedom.
Alec as Nick,
anything to do with,
that's not what it's about,
man.
Fuck Jesus.
You don't even fucking know.
It's just,
it seems to be,
out of all the things that are alike,
all the mysteries,
it's one of the most probable,
which is one of the most exciting things about it.
Like the loch ness monster.
Oh Man.
What are the idea that some long neck dinosaur thing is living in the middle of
a lake in Scotland?
Fucking get outta here.
I'm not buying it on that,
you know,
but I believe that more than bigfoot.
Do you lock nest 100% more?
See,
I don't.
I think that's way more unlikely.
It's way more unlikely that some sort of a cold blooded reptile that's enormous.
It lives in a lock has gone undetected for this long with a breeding population
that's way too open.
That's like,
even if you do,
I mean even if it is huge,
it's still just water.
You can find you.
You would see more of them.
You know what I'm saying?
It did exist.
I don't think it would exist.
Yes.
Well Dude Jenkin Oh,
Pythius thing that did exist.
That difference.
The difference between Unicorns and leprechauns and the lochness monster and big
foot mushrooms,
big foot,
probably big foot leaks,
leaves,
tracks.
If you want to meet the Leprechauns,
you can meet him.
You just got to take enough mushrooms.
You can meet leprechauns like you really can.
If you eat the proper dosage of any really potent psychedelic mushroom
psychedelics,
DMT with any,
anything that's a really intense transformative psychedelics,
you can see
things that make gremlins seemed totally normal.
I think that's the root of all that shit.
That's the root of all those.
I mean this is all people that were eating plants that they didn't even know
what the fuck they did.
They didn't understand the mechanisms behind them.
They had rituals around cultivating them and keeping them
okay.
That might be a part of the big foot thing too,
man.
I mean bigfoot might not even be a real thing.
It might be a real thing that you only can experience when you're having a
psychedelic trip,
like the idea of big foot in a physical sense.
It might not even be real.
It might be something that when you eat enough psychedelics,
it tunes into some part of your memory that recreates this thing that lived a
long time ago.
Best question asked about big foot.
It's not what it is is why?
Why,
why is it even there?
No.
The best question is,
is is it where the fuck has it?
Where the fuck is it?
You're looking for it.
You're asking the wrong questions.
That's what's wrong.
Okay.
This is like almost two hours.
I'm tapping it.
Yeah,
it's more than two hours.
It's almost three.
I'm tapping out.
Okay.
Survivor man,
big foot.
When is it airing?
When can people watch it?
Discovery Channel,
science channels.
Wednesdays,
Fridays.
Even if you're a nonbeliever,
ladies and gentlemen,
I rather recommend three bong hits and some good friends and you will enjoy this
God damn show Les Stroud Euro.
You're a fucking man's man.
I love Ya.
I'm always happy to talk to you.
I really do mean that if there's a Sasquatch out there,
I sincerely hope that you find it and I sincerely hope to really is a Sasquatch.
Would that be the cool Shit Brian is out?
No,
I don't know.
I mean,
if there was a such thing as a slash cross,
I don't know if it was cool,
I'd just be like,
there's a new monkey.
I don't think it's the coolest thing.
That would be way cooler.
No.
What if it talks like a Samurai,
if it talks like,
alright.
Um,
one more time.
When,
when can people watch it?
What network?
Discovery Channel.
Discovery.
Science Channel.
He's Fridays,
Wednesdays and Fridays.
At what time?
Usually 10 real less drought on Twitter.
Real less drought on Instagram.
Facebook.
Same thing.
Thank you,
man.
This is fine.
It's very impromptu.
Did it grab you from the comedy store?
Yes.
Perfect.
All right.
Goodnight everybody.
See Ya.
Okay.